[Music]
I'm the one
we got a special guest here all the way
from Buffalo New York
who got nine and a half hours of sleep
last night he just wrote a book called
why you don't need more than four hours
of sleep guys be ready Michael malice is
breaking in today I think we should have
probably recorded three minutes before
us going to the podcast literally Tom
was about to have his first fist fight
and it was going to be pretty intense
him and Michael going at it but it's
gonna be friends
good to have you on the podcast the
anarchist side of the Russians don't use
fists we use knives
that's that's uh yes what do Canadians
use time or they use apologies
I'm sorry
the Canadians don't apologize just the
quebecois which are sort of like
recycled French anyways um
this is what happens when you when you
have a guy that comes on a podcast it
takes half a second he describes himself
as an anarchist is that correct Michael
malice that is how I describe myself yes
without adjectives yes he has a book
that just came out a couple months ago
the white pill
a tale of Good and Evil yeah Michael
malice the man the myth the legend in
the flesh today uh how you been man how
you doing I am doing great uh relatively
yes yeah relatively so tell us your
sleep pattern you said you became an
author I think the audience wants to
know what is the so uh one of the I had
several reasons to become an author none
of which are particularly because I like
writing books or I was particularly good
at it but I wanted I had a list of
things I wanted to visualize and
accomplish in my life never have to talk
to someone I don't want to
um work for myself have a legacy and
also sleep in when I go my natural sleep
pattern so I go to bed at 2AM I wake up
at 11 and this I've been doing this for
years so whenever that's kind of messed
up I am just uh low-key Michael you
literally go to sleep at 2AM and you
wake up at 11. every day Monday through
Sunday so wait so when we said podcast 9
to 11 you thought it was late night no
no no no no no I didn't think that at
all you said come do the show and I said
sure then you're like oh it's 11. so you
did a bait and switch on me yeah you
never have a morning meeting in your
life Michael sends me a message I used
to do Glenn Beck's show uh in the
morning um and that was hell on Earth
I'll say one thing uh back to your
schedule is is the exact opposite of
what I was looking for in my life
because I used to work in nightlife in
Miami right and I was sick of waking up
at noon every single day I would go to
bed at four or five in the morning a
little later than you right and wake up
at noon and I was like I gotta get my
life together but that this is my
biorhythm Hey listen what's the point of
being successful if you can't set your
own terms Michael if those are your
buyers what audience wants to know is
what are your pronouns that's that's it
that's awesome sir okay so I got you and
if you can somehow convince Pat to get
on your schedule you were a great
salesman he should be on his schedule
yeah it might not work for him you
should take advantage of the whole
pronoun thing just make your pronouns
tired and shut up
I'm not tired I'm just kind of that's
this pattern Tom yeah what's wrong with
that you know you know what's crazy so
so yesterday while we're talking about
this yesterday I do my the the executive
physical that I do every every couple
years you're going at 6 30 in the
morning kind of time time you wake up
and and they literally take you from
Doctor to doctor to doctor and they test
everything right they check your heart
your skin your breathing your you know
everything they do it's phenomenal you
see nine or ten doctors in a span of
nine hours okay and
the lady asked me a question she said so
how much sleep do you get per night
and uh I felt compelled to sell her my
sleep pattern I said listen I just want
to let you know there you know that aura
ring thing that you people wear so yeah
so I wore it for like six months and
it's not
how much sleep you get is how much deep
sleep you get because according to or I
get a lot of deep sleep and she says
really I said yes she says you still
need to figure out a way to sleep seven
hours a night because I'm doing four to
six whatever the time is for me and I
said look it works for some it doesn't
work for some but it is what it is I
think that's what it is some people are
you know the whole morning person night
person I think there is some truth
behind that certain people are nice
you're awake in the morning you're not a
person there's something wrong with you
but early bird is not getting the worm
in your house they're getting a shotgun
but
the thing is I think extremely extremely
successful people often are the ones
whose uh evolutionary advantages that
get buying for as I sleep like Clinton
had four hours of sleep Thatcher
famously had four hours of sleep and
they could just get by you're getting
nine hours I'm getting ice I'm a failure
yeah I'm like Joe Biden's 12 to 15 we
hear it's sleep well if there's anything
you're not as a failure people love
listening to you your opinions but maybe
people thinking but maybe they're
failures yeah that's that's a that's a
person effective to have right you're
failing I'm winning I'm Michael malice
right I'm the white pill guy anyways
okay so for the audience that doesn't
know you Michael take a uh um we did a
podcast together it was a zoom it was
the first time we had an interaction
together and I was trying to learn about
you a lot of people kept saying Pat you
got to talk to this guy you got to talk
to this guy we had a great conversation
that's why I'm here and he messages me
says you said I thought we had a good
conversation like Michael we had a very
good conversation we were trying to get
on the podcast so our Booker
we were trying to get a time to get on
the podcast they're like hey Michael not
right now maybe later than any anyways
we eventually made it work wait that's
not what happened at all yeah he said do
you want to do the show I said yes I
don't hear from him I check in and then
he goes they're not interested it wasn't
later it was like it's a no but the
guy's name is who who was Ellen
something Allen that's not our Booker
right that's our Booker he also texted
my sister somehow yeah so so did I by
the way but that was a separation
she likes her sleep also in different
ways you know you know I I
listen you want subtle I'll do it 11 pm
Michael give us your background so how
how does one like you they don't know
like come become you know who you are
today with your ideas tell us tell us
get your ideas from
um I don't what do you mean can you what
do you mean by that question exactly
what I ask you like how did you come up
with the ideas that you have today was
it well I didn't come up with them per
se I mean a lot of my ideas being an
anarchist
um are historically you know I did
something called the anarchistamic which
we discussed it was a collection of uh
the tradition of anarchism and this
tagline for the book is the Black Flag
comes in many colors because there are
different schools of anarchism but
basically anarchism is the understanding
that uh political Authority is
illegitimate and uh you do not speak for
me and everything else is just
application
so when you're saying enter we've
interviewed Libertarians Democrats
Republicans progressives I for me this
is my first Anarchist well Dave Smith's
been on he's a very failed eggest yeah
he's more Olympic field I like that yeah
he's your most frequent guest I think
you said yeah when we did the lockdowns
we did yeah I think he's a stud but
stuck okay
listen I know there's that line about
you got to wake up pretty in the morning
but the convince me that Dave Smith's a
stud you really got to wake me up early
in the morning six hours of sleep Dave's
a six hours yeah you know in his in his
mind that's a stud and by the way you're
talking to a guy that also respects
people who get proper ample amount of
sleep okay so he's part of the Ariana
Huffington you're gonna ask the question
Dave sleepy Dave well anyway so you're
you're unique so for I guess part of
Pat's questioning yeah you're a nice guy
so for you you're probably like I'm an
anarchist it's like I roll out of bed at
you know noon it's what I do I'm an
anarchist I but for the most of the
people in the audience probably not too
familiar with what the the substantive
beliefs of Anarchy or when I hear
Anarchy I'm like this guy's a wild man
but you seem pretty you know nice guy so
explain what Anarchy is and why people
should maybe consider that for their
ideology well I remember when I was in
college we I was taking a bioethics
Course and there was this kind of chart
that spanned the the range of what the
bioethics range of ideas were and in one
chart one part of the chart was legalism
which is basically the idea that what
the government defines as moral is moral
and the other half is that antinomianism
which is the belief that it morals are
independent of the law and the the
author went on to say Well since No One
Believes In antidomianism it's somewhere
else in this chart well that is the
belief in antinomialism that something
is not moral since simply because it's
legal and something is not immoral
simply because it's legal that morality
precedes law and that uh politicians or
you know anyone else who kinds tries to
assume Authority have to be held
accountable to a higher power but also
the belief that you know government
democracy all these things are
inherently illegitimate and can never be
made valid or coherent even so you're
saying there's a difference between
morality and legality yes and I don't
think that's a particularly
controversial perspective of that aspect
of anarchism and then who how do you
define morality and who's who's the
authority on morality this is what the
Bible is it God is it Jesus is it
Muhammad what do you come with morale is
it human Muhammad
that's the Jew yes I really bet on the
wrong Bank on this one
um no I I morality is something Rand
Ironman talks about very frequently and
this again is independent of anarchism
morality is something that we all have
to deal with we have no choice we all
have to face moral issues on a daily
basis we may not tend to think of them
as moral like okay am I going to go to
the school to check up on how my kid's
doing or am I going to spend time at
business or am I going to be with my
mistress these are all moral questions
even though there may not be framed
maybe the last one most certainly would
be so the point being that morality and
our conscience is something that is
inescapable and there are very many
mechanisms uh promulgated by the
corporate press to try to make things
seem morally ambiguous or seem morally
uh Incorrect and this is just you know
one of the other many reasons why I and
so many other people not specifically
anarchists have so much contempt for
corporate journalists by the way just
search uh uh what is anarchy right
anarcho pacifism okay yeah is a form of
anarchism which completely rejects the
use of violence in any form for any
purpose
the main precedent was Henry David
Thoreau yes who uh through his work
Civil Disobedience influenced both Leo
Tolstoy and Mahatma Gandhi's advocacy of
non-violent resistance right so I think
when you and I talked last time I'm
trying to I asked I said would that be
possible today in America you were
pretty confident that it wouldn't be
hard to get there so if if we if we
wanted to if if you had it your way
let's just say today Michael malice wins
2024 election on nine hours of sleep how
am I running am I running for office I
know you're not but let's just say if
you are okay dreaming and you're you're
a you're able to do certain policies
that you would like to implement in U.S
what would some of those policies be you
mean like what kind of guillotines there
you go that's one French Revolution
Vibes who goes first I I I I I I mean I
don't okay great question this is what
happens when you wake me up early
this is what happens
because I do have a list no um I do not
believe the list I'm not even really
kidding I don't believe that someone can
ethically be a politician and serve But
to answer your question in a different
way no I'm not a pacifist and the only
policies I would be interested in doing
is to uh you know destroy as many swaths
of government as possible and to have
consequences for government officials as
much as possible for their depravity
so get rid of so if you don't then the
government runs without having any
politicians and the people are managing
themselves with the laws and the
guidelines and the rules all of that
that's that's kind of it's not
necessarily matching themselves for
example if I go to like a department
store right there's a system of
governance in place I can no shirts no
shoes no Services something like that
there's some store will have you can
return things some stores have it you
can't return things so basically you
would have this kind of localized uh
excuse me very localized very
decentralized sense of governance
because there's this kind of myth that
uh anarchism is the idea of no rules but
that's not accurate at all if I go to
your house you know if you're having a
white party and I gotta wear white it's
certainly within your rights to say
you're not wearing white get the F out
of my house so it is you know it is
inescapable that someone is going to
have jurisdiction over certain areas the
point being to have someone insinuate
themselves as the state in between these
relationships is illegitimate
how does that look like so so let's so
so you're saying it would be
self-regulated like we would
self-regulate we do that now again I'm
here I I came at your time I am doing
your podcast I can't just do whatever I
want I'm following certain principles
and then if I don't at a certain point
you can either tell me to leave or if it
gets extreme you call security so this
is something that not only is not
hypothetical it's something we live 24 7
you know 365 days a year and uh
anarchism is you know voluntary
cooperation in exchange is the basis of
any healthy society and the problems
only come through public crime
governments or private crime criminals
so if that's the case we're we're right
now what country today is running on
that system so anarchism isn't a
location anarchism is a relationship so
anytime you have two people or two
organizations or two entities or more
where they have no semblance of
authority higher than them that is an
anarchist relationship and let me give
you a good example we don't have a world
government right so if an American I
apologize for this and if an American
kills the Canadian in Mexico who has
jurisdiction no one but they still have
some mechanism in place between the
three of them because every country is
in a state of anarchism toward every
other country so anarchism again isn't
like a place it's a relationship between
different entities how does that work in
interpersonal relationships so let's say
with a husband and wife or a business
husband's in charge that's it bottom
line it's the best answer I'm gonna hear
all day that's what Muhammad was right
yeah okay so it's it almost sounds like
you sound like a pastor it's like you
know you got to have a relationship with
God it's what it is you know it's not a
Christianity is not a religion it's it's
a relationship with God you know Muslim
is not it's a relationship it's a
relationship but at the same time if you
say anarchy so if if because the way you
sound you sound super convincing okay
and and and you're a you're obviously
very sharp guy your history stuff you
you know guys coming up to you helping
out with writing you do such a good job
they thank you but they say please let's
make sure we don't have to say that you
did this because of your background and
what you believe in you're a very sharp
guy with your background you've been on
Rogan I don't know how many times you've
been on Rogue uh it's either eight or
six okay that's a lot of times to be on
Roblox he pulled two episodes because we
had the n-word okay so E6 got it Anarchy
but but but okay so but when you sound
convincing if it's that convincing
Michael why aren't more people doing it
is it the argument
is I'll tell you I can ask you a
question yeah absolutely so there's an
essay in the anarchist handbook by Emma
Goldman and she gets into why the
majority cannot reason so the vast
majority of people are not capable of
rational discourse particularly when it
comes to politics so any kind of and
democracy exploits this uh first of all
they don't often have time but second
they often don't have mental capacity
but again it's the popularity of an idea
is not at all a testament to its
veracity or lack of veracity if that
were true then the funniest show in
history would be how uh The Big Bang
Theory uh which of course I don't think
anyone will say with a straight face is
the case but that's the most popular
sitcom that that either now or has ever
been so one of the there are several
reasons one is why it's not more popular
people in power especially those who are
in power illegitimately have an enormous
best interest and enormous incentive to
maintain their power and to increase
their power and for over a century now
uh the state has been raising America's
children as its own uh taking them since
now they want it younger and younger and
inculcating them with ideas that if you
received them for the first time as an
adult you would regard as absurd but
since you've been kind of trained to
accept them as plausible since you're
four or five years old you don't even
bat an eye when you're the repeated to
you as an adult such as the idea that we
all understand here in this room maybe
it's different for the Canadian that
aristocracy is illegitimate right just
someone was born to some King and now
this guy is going to some Queen and now
this person is going to have some kind
of
um position to dictate terms of your
life take money for me this is crazy but
somehow if there's a lot of your
neighbors believe something that they
now as a group have the power to take
your freedoms away that is regard to
sanity it's in in the anarchist
perspective it's complete as completely
insane what was the first Anarchy
Community what was the first Anarchy
Community the for I don't know what you
would what you would consider the first
Anarchist I'm just Googling it right now
and I put Anarchy and it says list of
anarchist communities so pedios so which
one would be meaning because you said
it's not a country it's a relationship
right that's what you said again so
these little communities are very much
kind of the in the anarcho-capitalist
excuse me a narco-communist way and they
often didn't last very long yeah I guess
so but the idea of Anarchy what was the
first Inception of the idea of Anarchy
what year was that again it again zero
the year 5000 BC and anarchism again is
a relationship so whenever you have
people interacting with each other
without any kind of sovereign or a ruler
over them that is an example of
anarchism working it's not a place and
it's not a time well so an example would
be two friends yeah here we go I'll give
you some examples okay ready here are
some examples stop Googling listen
listen I'm going to read this to you I
want to read this to you give me the
idea Anarchy is a society without a
government okay okay it may also I don't
care what the computer says I'm just
because for me it's for smart guys like
you you don't need it I'm I'm trying to
get you know but I don't think Wikipedia
is I know let me just read this Michael
okay so Anarchy is a society without a
government it may also refer to society
or group of people that entirely rejects
a set hierarchy okay Anarchy was first
used in English dictionary in 1539 an
absence of government that's kind of
what I was wanting to know like when did
it get started so 1539 the idea came
about like first time using a dictionary
Pierre Joseph proutin adopted Anarchy
and Anarchist in his 1840 treaties what
is property and then it goes into
explaining the rest of us but go ahead
you were going to say something about
Anarchy with a relationship of friends
just because the word was used for the
first time in a certain year does not
mean the concept or the philosophy was
original to that your time I'll give you
examples of anarchism working music
Cuisine mathematics astronomy these are
all Anarchist systems meaning there is
no Sovereign there's no government
regulating it these are individuals and
organizations working together
voluntarily and creating systems those
are all examples of working Anarchist
systems
the question becomes can that be uh uh
can those philosophy so so for you if
Anarchy is a relationship and it's used
in those different uh sects then then
what would be an ideal situation for you
for there to not be a government well I
don't I know about ideal because I think
when you start getting into ideals it
starts becoming a little bit incoherent
but yes and not necessarily not be a
government but the understanding that
the government is inherently
illegitimate and frankly a lot of what
the government does and I'm sorry I have
my back to you by the way uh a lot of
what the government does is a function
of so many people being trained to
regard it as legitimate and basically
bend the knee when they should otherwise
have to
interesting you were going to say go
ahead with the music yeah okay so the
examples were used on the music side if
you can elaborate I think part of the
reason that Pat's Googling stuff and I'm
asking these questions is because we
generally don't know about this kind of
stuff so for you you're like I talk
about this every single day come on yeah
no I'm saying that Wikipedia is often a
very incoherent and poor resource when
you're dealing with fair enough but I
mean it gives us a a good Baseline for
what's going on I think it gives a bad
that's my point if you're starting
you're a true anarchistry I just don't
regard Wikipedia as really a coherent
resource when it comes to most things I
don't think it's a controversial opinion
okay so why don't we go a little bit
more modern while uh Tom's got a
question for him can you uh Rob maybe
this is at his standard and before we go
into Chad gbt and what Anarchy is good
for sponsor goldco okay with all the
mess going on right now in the economy
the all the mess that's going on with
Silicon Valley Bank all the
conversations uh people are having uh
even just this week do I move my money
out of this do I move my money out of
debt nobody can predict what's going on
today not the biggest experts uh just a
few months ago a guy named Kramer not
even a few months ago a month ago Kramer
saying wow Silicon Valley Bank it's a
good buy it's this it said and that's
the guy that's supposed to be the one
everybody takes advice from boom next
thing you know Silicon Valley Bank 200
billion dollar company goes uh belly up
and now people are looking at other
places that this could happen to which
we'll cover here in the podcast
momentarily that's the point you can't
predict the future I cannot predict the
future the whole part is about how we
can hedge against what could possibly
happen and one of the ways to hedge
against a market crash is to have gold
in your portfolio a small percentage of
your money you ought to consider having
into gold and the company we work with
is gold Co we've done a lot of research
on these guys they got plenty of
positive reviews I've talked to people
that have worked there directly people
that I've known for 15 16 years and so
for us uh uh Gold Coast a six-time Inc
5000 winner 2022 company of the year
with billions of fives with thousands of
5 Star reviews and they've helped people
like you and me place over a billion
dollars in gold and silver value timing
viewers could get up to ten thousand
dollars in free silver and a one a free
one ounce silver Ronald Reagan coin with
a qualified order I don't think he was
an anarchist and called them today at
855-594-2758-855-594-2758 or go to
goldco.com forward slash pbd goldco.com
forward slash pbd Rob tell us what chat
gbt maybe that's at Michael standards
because Wikipedia is obviously
questionable by everybody okay you're
right yeah what is chat what Anarchy
yeah exactly did you question it already
or no is is it currently that capacity
but I may be able to try it over here
yeah you keep doing what you're doing
when you get it let us know you had one
job
yeah rob you can't even get on chat gbt
it sounds like complete Anarchy what's
going on in chat GPT had a rough couple
weeks even though I know he's doing his
best but go ahead so a question for you
yeah every now and then
um uh whether it's missionaries or
anthropologists discover small groups of
people indigenous people that have
hithers have been not discovered and
observation is they have some very basic
mores and folkways and they've just sort
of assembled among themselves would you
call that
Anarchist groups no because they almost
they always if I I want to say almost
always because I'm not Anthropologist
but they do have a very rigid uh legal
and hierarchical structure there's a
Chieftain uh and and there are laws that
are enforced so and so even though
absent influence of any of the
government structures or but they do
have a government store they have a
Judicial System it's just primitive
right there can I finish sure okay
um so they're absent to any of like oh
you live in Luxembourg and there's the
king or whatever they're they've been
absent that there hasn't been an outside
influence on them like that they've just
grown inside but because they've grown a
hierarchical structure maybe it's
patriarchal whatever it is that is their
government and therefore they're that's
not an anarchist group right and I think
it also depend on the size right I don't
think I think some of these primitive
societies are actually quite are not
just like the Dozen people they're
actually quite sizable and do have a
functional government structure
something that just came to my head so
where do you stand on the whole
um defund the police because obviously
police or even military this is part of
government I'm for police abolition uh
and and having the market provide
security uh whenever you have the
government having its security is far
too important of a service to have a
monopoly on it let alone a Government
monopoly and when you have a Government
monopoly on any product or service the
consequence is always Strife uh
shortages and other negative
externalities so you want the free
market to uh
be the authority on anything Security
Police I wouldn't say the authority but
yes the Primo the free market provides
which provides security far better just
in a way that provides food far better
education far better uh and all
everything else far better than would uh
um the Government monopoly no well
there's no accountability when it comes
to having any kind of Monopoly people
understand this about you know if you
had like let's suppose an oil Monopoly
which never happened but let's suppose
you know a monopoly that Monopoly is not
going to be accountable to Consumers of
the market but when you have a
Government monopoly somehow insecurity
everyone's like well what are you going
to do well the answer is to have
decentralization and also to have a um
as much of an armed population as
possible and then and how does uh Law
and Order Constitution just basic
framework of what's going on in
democracy how would that so
um
anarchism is the mother of God or not
the daughter so if you have again the
best way to have order between any kind
of peoples or organizations is to have
it be voluntary and agreed upon so they
have contracts right if I go into a
business with you we sit down ahead of
time and basically work out the divorce
we're like all right these are your
responsibilities these are my
responsibilities what happens if you
know you get sick and you can't work it
out what happens if I get sick if I
don't fulfill my terms of the contract
so whenever you have any sort of
voluntary
um interchange between two people or two
or more organizations it's going to be
far more Peaceable and when you have far
more of an idea of self-reliance and you
have accountability in the entities that
are providing any given service it's
going to be far more efficient and far
more pervasive and widely available food
used to be a huge problem even in this
country nowadays you know the problem is
there's too much food and everyone's
obese so clothing is another one we make
so many clothes you know back in the day
people had one pair of shoes and you
have to wear it all your life now we
have so many clothes we're shipping him
overseas and there's literally landfills
of these crappy t-shirts what do you
think about communism well that's the
point of this book okay tell us about it
well it's really bad uh the point of
writing the white pill and this has
nothing to do with anarchism at all
um the book uh the point of the white
pill is I was kind of disquieted you
know being born in the former Soviet
Union to what extent it has been almost
being forgotten and this is something
that ended in our lifetime the lifetime
of everyone here and probably of the
vast majority of people listening as
well and what people went through for
decades on the far side of the Iron
Curtain was so disturbing and also so
hard for us to wrap our heads around we
let's I don't know if any of you have
diabetes I don't right if someone tried
to tell you what it's like living with
diabetes you're it's going to be very
different from actually living it right
we can wrap our heads right okay I can't
have candy are there other health
externalities you know can I exercise
maybe I'm gonna if I want to take a
marathon I'm gonna have to do certain
things it's we're still not going to get
there intellectually unless you live it
so we can maybe understand okay I'm in
school I'm taught certain things or
someone's listening to me on the phone
or people get arrested and you're
powerless doing anything about it we can
maybe understand each of those elements
individually but in terms of
understanding that pervasive atmosphere
the tagline of the book it's let me get
the exact quote when Rand was testifying
in front of Congress she said it's
almost impossible to convey to a free
people what it's like to live in a
totalitarian dictatorship
so I try to explain throughout the
course of this book just what it was
like and even I don't really understand
it my protege was just in Prague they
have something there called The Museum
of Communism and that you know what's
great about this museum is it's not
written this western style in a
scholarly manner because it's like
according to these demented ideas we're
all supposed to have food but instead we
were starving and when I was when he's
sending all the photos of the captions
because I wanted to quote one for the
book it made me appreciate for the first
time what it was like for my family in
the sense of totalitarianism you know
this is a stupid pun but it's not a pun
but it means total so it's everywhere
there's nowhere to go from the moment
you're born till the time you die and
you're told you can't leave so let's
suppose there's a politician you hate or
you hate politics in general you hate
Trump you think Biden's a fool you can
watch sports you can listen to music you
can read books historical books or
contemporary books yes they're trying to
put politics into everything but there's
certainly very many venues where you
could Escape or even just talking to
your friends they didn't have that and
even just talking to your friends you
have to wonder all right did Pat turn is
so or someone is someone did someone get
to him or is he just doing this for
status for money so that kind of sense
of having something the government and
that ideology govern every aspect of
your life is something that I think is
important for those of us who love any
semblance of Freedom Republican or
Democrat to appreciate so you know that
argument again uh um goes to
that could work for those that are
independent they can take care of
themselves uh but if if you if you can't
and you and I have to police everybody
do I already want to deal with police
and everybody do I already wanna you
know if if there isn't uh so so what are
you growing your own food what do you
think about Law and Order what do you
think about law what do you think about
Law and Order wait hold on are you
growing your own food what do you think
about Law and Order I I I'm in favor of
order I don't think law is a good
mechanism of getting order
okay so what order are you a fan of just
the people in the community deciding
what it is or I'm in favor of people
behaving peacefully which is
overwhelming the norm and in fact the
problem is that so much crime is granted
legitimacy and is not punished as a
consequence due to having a monopoly in
policing
okay so you're not a fan of law now I I
think having a monopoly means that
product or service is not going to be
distributed well or if at all we have
right now and no one even thinks this is
weird prosecutors a lot of times I'll be
like yeah I'm not going to prosecute
this how is that law that's crazy
I understand you're taking one one
element of it but if you uh we had
Gordon Chang on I don't know if you know
Gordon Chen is so Gordon Chen who lived
in China for 20 some years and uh he
says China was a mess when there was no
law because little to no law and he says
in 1984 some number like that he said
there was 40 uh universities that gave
away law degrees because it wasn't
something that was popular and they
realized capitalism uh doesn't work
without laws because somebody can bully
and take advantage of the other person
what is your POV of not needing laws
wait wait I I I find it crazy to think
that there's no bullying in China
especially via the state I mean the
whole point of the Communists less than
before this is why their Innovation grew
the way it has the last 40 years because
they added laws which they didn't have
before but they they did have laws but
that law is basically the will of
whoever the CP official was like and
that's the problem
the problem is the laws don't apply to
you know Joe Biden or Donald Trump like
they would apply to you or me or to
someone who's much poorer than us if you
had a system where services are provided
uh by Freedom uh it's going to be a lot
more Equitable and it's going to be a
lot more coherent because if I am trying
to get I'm promoting a product or
service I need to be able to put my
money where my mouth is whereas if a cop
shoots someone it's like well oops
you're just going to be suspended and
get a pension it's absolutely the double
standard between something with the
Monopoly and something that is provided
when there's an element of competition
is just night and day so you're saying
if there's no cops people won't ride I'm
just saying there's no I was saying if
there's no Government monopoly there's
no government cops let's just say
there's no government I'll give you an
example that's happening this isn't
hypothetical yeah so everyone here if
you go to a bar which is full of young
males full of testosterone and alcohol
it is still safer there than in the
places where the government is providing
security such as city parks and night
alleys the Subways when you have there's
no incentive for a Government monopoly
to provide its service and in fact the
worse it provides a service the more
taxes the politicians are there in a
position to demand that the populace pay
in because they could say look we have a
problem we need more of this we need
more of that so when things are provided
privately and you at hotels is another
good example everyone in a hotel is uh
not native to the area where they're in
it's still safer in a hotel than in
public housing where everyone actually
lives there and you know who lives there
you sound so convincing how do you argue
with this but but here's a part you
sound so convincing if your ideas are so
perfect the way you sell them how come
others are not implementing it you can't
tell me it's because well you know the
way the world has ruled is the people of
Power are so power hungry that they
eventually go up there and all of them
unite and they don't want to do anything
thinking they're not willing to give up
their powers and their Privileges and
this is why the idea of Anarchy has
never been because I get it and these
other guys don't right so if it's so
perfect the way you do it you say
perfect if it's if it's as good as the
way you sell it right why aren't smart
people out there implementing it because
the government co-ops smart people the
whole point of our University system is
to train the next generation of maybe
80. you want to hear my answer maybe 80
there's a couple of things first of all
is I should I think all of us would
agree here yeah that alcohol prohibition
was a bad idea which did not I don't
think at all decrease the amount of
alcohol consumption in this country or
maybe marginally but vastly increase the
amount of crime in this country how was
it that alcohol prohibition was such a
popular idea that it got two-thirds of
the Congress and uh was it three
quarters of the states to ratify it
because there's very many examples
to broader speaking politics are
non-rational
there's an entire system in place where
people will vote for their tribe as
opposed to the other tribe and not
really care if any of their ideas or
views are implemented just so long as
their team wins and we which is
something we're taught if you ask
conservatives why are you voting for Dr
Oz He supported Jesse Smollett he
supported uh uh trans kids they're gonna
say well what do you want me to do Vote
for fetterman This these are my only
options so we're trained since kids that
your only options are voting and those
two choices are Republican or Democrat
no I don't disagree with that I don't
disagree with with what you just said
and also one more thing just sorry this
is very key because
um
Noam Chomsky who's also an anarchist a
prominent linguist as well he has this
great quote I'm sorry I'm going to
butcher the exact wording he goes the
way to control a society is to have
strictly delineated terms of argument
but have very vigorous debate between
those terms so you're a Jimmy Dora I
don't know if you ever had him on the
show just great I'm surprised gnome said
that and when I asked him if he would
ever debate Thomas Soul he avoided it
well I'm not surprised at this price
yeah I'm very surprised he didn't want
to talk to Thomas yeah he was on two
weeks ago Jimmy's great but he he gave
an example of this like if you watch
like the view the choices are going to
be should we can I curse yeah should we
bomb the [__] out of Syria or should we
bomb the [__] [__] out of Syria right
we're always presented with a very
limited range of options on and then you
think okay I either have CNN or Fox but
that's basically where the Overton
window lies so any ideas that are
radical threat to the governing
structure are going to be marginalized
and you're going to be told until very
recently when you had independent venues
like this this that you're crazy or this
is impossible or it'll never happen and
for many people there is a still to this
day there is a huge social cost in
adopting an there's a huge social cost
in adopting an ideology that's regarded
as marginal or unpopular I don't know
about that everything is a social cost
no I I I I I okay so what I think you're
doing is super necessary is because
you're you're making people think right
you're making people think and say okay
he sounds convincing he sounds very
confident doesn't necessarily mean
you're right but it's good the fact that
you're we're having this Discord right
and the audience can be like well Pat
you made a good point you don't know
what you're talking about you need to do
your research on this but you got to go
read this here's one okay well Michael
you Patrick asked that question you
didn't really give the right answer them
great let them decide on what they want
to do but but here's the part so what I
think has happened the last few years is
we've shown with this tool we got right
now whatever 9 100 people live watch and
by the time this is going to be done
within a two-hour period 100 000 people
will watch it 24 hours all the clips
together say we got four or five million
people that watch this to get this
argument okay
we didn't have this 20 years ago correct
right so 20 years ago
Michael malice you would have had to
gone the traditional way of maybe
instead of sleeping nine hours you would
have slept in seven and a half hours to
make it because a tool like this is an
out there to Market it so it would have
been much harder for a guy like you to
make it to where you are today right
today the tools allow you to live the
life that you've always dreamed about
living which is phenomenal yes however
here's what I think is this tool is
given
and you may disagree if 20 years ago
somebody said guys
in 20 years
trans people are going to be accepted
men are going to be transitioning into
uh women and competing and the
Democratic party who's always been they
claim they're four women they're
feminists
they're going to be okay with men
saying they're women
competing against women beating records
and they're going to be cornered to and
trans they're going to be all over the
place and Drew Barrymore is going to
bring a person in Dylan
and she's going to get on her knees in
front of him and say I totally
understand your pain that'll never
happen I'm telling us what's going to
happen but let me tell you what else is
going to happen what's that you don't
think these CNN the fox all these guys
yeah what about them they're gonna get
crushed
by this guy named Joe
what are you talking about regular it's
just a regular Joe he's not a regular
Joe I'm telling you CNN and fox are
going to be crushed by a guy named Joe
what does this guy do is he a
billionaire does he have more money than
them no he just talks and makes people
think and brings different people on so
what has he done do you know marijuana
that it's illegal today yeah that guy's
gonna make people think marijuana is not
a big deal and matter of fact he's going
to bring the richest guy in the world on
and that guy's gonna smoke weed
and then he's gonna the next day the
Market's gonna come after him but now
smoking weed is no longer what it was
before get the hell out of you Michael
you're out of your mind that'll never
happen in America conservative no it is
it is I'm telling you and you're not
even going to think twice when last week
I mean Bahamas three four days ago I
mean the other day I'm in a game we'll
walk by my kids what is that smell it's
a uh what is that animal that smells
like weed it's a uh skunk skunk oh
that's what a skunk smells like you
didn't know yeah that's a skunk I'm like
oh really yeah that's a skunk sound
that's what it is okay cool that's not
skunk man it's like five minutes later
Dylan's smiling I'm like no wonder this
guy's so happy right now so no one cares
about smoking weed today 20 years ago
was crazy so this is the point I'm
trying to make to you Michael and take
this personally I want you to get upset
I'm not gonna get it and say screw you
Pat I'm not gonna say yeah that's good
here's what I would say
if the last 20 years some of the
craziest wackiest ideas
are now being talked about and some of
the things that the conservatives would
have never accepted are now saying it's
just weed maybe your argument isn't that
good or maybe you're just not good at
presenting your argument for other
people to pick it up because if there's
ever been a time to sell your
philosophies to be received by millions
of people around the world now is the
time how come there's not that kind of
momentum yet the anarchist handbook hit
number three on Amazon uh 20 years ago
that book wouldn't have been published
uh so if you're asking me why we haven't
gone from uh the state in 2003 to
anarchism today I haven't been at it
that long secondly I don't think you're
going to deny regard if you look at
social media and other outlets which are
imperfect but certainly uh loose vectors
uh or metrics rather by how popular
ideas are the views that I'm putting
forward are infinitely more popular than
they were 20 years ago and it is a
result of exactly what you're talking
about the fact that now you do not when
we were before we were born I think you
and I around the same age you had three
television stations and it's ABC NBC CBS
and if you argue if you went back in
time and you're like you've got they're
like we have choices my friend really
loves CBS but he's an idiot you know you
got to listen to ABC and what it all was
was corporate media and they all
basically had the same message if not
it's not identical message nowadays then
Fox started and it's like oh my God we
have Fox we gotta put fox out of
business these people are crazy I think
most people need it enough to look at
Fox they think that the average age of a
fox viewer is deceased and that it is to
regard Fox as a vector of kind of
radicalism as opposed to maybe like a
hardcore Republican Outlet is absurd
you're not going to really find much
radicalism on Fox other than maybe
sometimes the master of the way you know
what would be a great commercial you
know would be a great commercial you
just give give me an idea if CNN or or
any of these guys wanted to kind of make
a commercial to bashfox all they have to
do is go uh rent out a cemetery put a TV
there and Fox TV all over the place
saying the only people that listen to
Fox are dead people listen to CNN listen
to ABC that'd be a that'd be a pretty
let me let me ask you this so your your
position is that it's a great thing that
this train this trans steps happening in
sports
uh no I don't think I'm just saying if
if a crazy idea like that has created
this kind of momentum how come your
wonderful idea hasn't but I don't think
that ideas uh uh necessarily become
popular as a function of how true or or
but I think Joe's idea is a great idea
to create a momentum and people who were
not on his side said that makes sense
right so what I'm saying is sometimes
great ideas do Catch Fire and become
popular and sometimes really deranged
ideas do Catch Fire and become popular
because we do because how ideas are
formed in this country and in most
countries isn't a function of people sit
down they do the research they look at
both sides and they kind of maybe argue
with their neighbors this is just this
Enlightenment delusion about how people
come to the conclusions people far often
read Jonathan Heights book The Righteous
Mind people come to their uh um
political conclusions for evolutionary
reasons meaning I wanted the bandwagon
effect you know when uh after Kennedy
was shot they asked people who you voted
for in the 1960 election which was the
closest selection in history and the
percentage of people who had remembered
I think sincerely that they had voted
with Kenny over Nixon was far more than
the number of people actually did it
because we tend to want to think of
ourselves as being on The Winning Side
low status people have an enormous
incentive to not rock the boat because
they're not in a position to kind of
have radical ideas because think about
if I go to an office and I have some
kind of wacky ideology and I'm not
empowered right away I'm out group so
this is one of the many reasons why
ideas that are radical are not necessary
but but it's something broader I don't
care about popularity of an idea because
I don't think politics is moved by the
majority politics is often I don't
disagree let me just finish politics is
always moved by an informed ideological
usually radicalized minority and this
country was founded by a bunch of very
small percentage of people who had a
vision and they didn't even bother
asking the masses what they thought so
then that then that says if since 1539
this has been an idea how come it's died
I don't think it's died at all I think
the idea that government is inherently
legitimate is more popular now I don't
think that's an anarchy philosophy I
think that is that's the definition of
Anarchy no but but a lot of people both
on the left and the right would agree
that the government uh is too big I
didn't say too big not the government
government itself the concept so in your
world there shouldn't be a government or
the idea of the government is not
legitimate yes I don't think people
would say the legitimate define
legitimate something uh legitimate for a
government to be legitimate means it is
in a moral position to enact its edicts
upon its subjects
okay so so if if so in in other words I
don't think government is a legitimate
meaning it's not necessary no it's
doesn't like I don't have a right to go
in your wallet and take money right but
somehow the withholding tax is where
people think well you pack taxes are the
price you pay for civilized society that
to me and to other anarchists is not
legitimate how far off are you from uh
Iran's philosophy well Rand hated
anarchists uh she's on the cover of the
book you know she's the first chapter is
her testifying in front of the house on
America Activities Committee if you it's
funny because you know her kind of
objectivism I don't like calling it a
cult but it basically has cult-like
aspects but what she describes as Gulch
in Atlas Shrugged is effectively a
private Anarchist Community who else is
on that book by the way uh it's not sure
Margaret Thatcher Emma Goldman and Elena
chachescu and why'd you pick those four
um I wanted the since the book is
dealing about uh starving the holiday
more starving millions of people in
Ukraine concentration camps the gulags
um the show trials the Stasi uh and
ultimately the fall of um the Soviet
Union and its uh subject satellite
States I wanted the there's a Jane
wiedlin was a singer it was excuse me
the Rhythm guitars for the Go-Go's and
she had this comment about their music
which is a very new wave music that it
sounds very chipper but if you look at
the lyrics they're very very sad so I
wanted the cover to be like all right
the content is going to be very very
dark but I want it to be like sunny and
almost silly
um so the cover looks like kind of like
a 1970s like a movie poster or play
poster and you would think it's kind of
a romance novel but I wanted to have
that bright sunny cover given that the
contents are so dark and disturbing
Michael were you born in Ukraine yes sir
okay so what do you think about what's
going on right now in Ukraine I don't
think I have a very informed perspective
on what's going on my big concern my
background you know we talked before I
did a book on North Korea called dear
reader about Kim Jong-il and my big
concern is that we're facing a
replication of the Korean war in the
Korean War you had North Korea with the
great leader Kimmel sung backed by Mao
and Stalin China Russia China and Russia
respectively you had sigmundry in the
South backed by the U.S and the U.N it
winded up happening is Korea the Korean
Peninsula was leveled and the
devastation for the people was enormous
so I'm very concerned that there is
enormous pressure understandably to not
reach any kind of settlement
um and that the people who are going to
end up paying the price of the Ukrainian
people that's my concern people who are
going to end up paying the price of
Ukrainian people if they don't find a
way to settle or even it seems like
there's no good solution here right
because if they're settling it you're
going to say okay not you I mean the
argument is you're validating Putin's
aggression he's going to do it again
that's a fair argument then it's like
well you can't settle not give an inch
but then like yeah but you're we're here
in America we're not paying the price
but in Anarchy philosophy you've got to
kind of leave it alone right and let
them kind of do their own part I I I I
don't think this is really a question of
libertarian Republican Democrat or
Anarchist I think this is just a
question of right what are what is the
facts of the matter and I don't think I
have the facts on this issue how is that
possible you you it's like you're
Homeland like if something happens this
is my homeland no I left here but I get
that but like even uh is there any
Affinity to Ukraine for you none zero no
we speak we spoke Russian I don't even
speak Ukrainian so you were born in
Ukraine I left when I was one to half so
it's not like I found memories it's not
like we left because it was so great and
again but this was the Soviet Union so
Ukraine in 78 is going to be very
different from Ukraine in 2023 and also
Moscow in 78 it's going to be a
difference that's a little strange
though you're a pretty well-read guy and
you're a pretty smart guy to say I don't
like uh uh oh you know I don't have any
uh opinion on the country I was born in
that's going like it's the topic of
discussion on every single Channel right
now yeah uh okay so if they're so it's
okay so let's do you support the fact
that U.S is given the kind of money
they're giving and their uh uh helping
them out in this war in a proxy war type
of a thing that's going on do you
support that I would I don't know
because I don't know where this is going
are we going to say that we're going to
just fund it it terminally yeah uh is it
or because that seems to be the premise
in which case the ukrainians are going
to be emboldened to fight and then one
day what are we gonna do Cut and Run and
then they're left holding the bag so
that is my concern
okay
it's here's the thing it's not like
Ukraine Russia or the us are going to
somehow regard disregard the legitimacy
of government overnight so this is not a
situation where there's like a like an
anarchist answer or I'm in a position or
an authority to speak for anarchism then
then if that's the case the Anarchy will
never happen if that's the case it's
happening right now this is us and this
is anarchism no but this is at a very
very low level Anarchy well let me let
me rephrase that for Anarchy to happen
at the highest level based on what
you're saying it'll never happen but
there is no highest level under
anarchism the whole point is that if
fine if you want to say that anarchism
can only work in a small community fine
let us have our community and leave us
alone okay so that's then that's what
you are then you would you would uh you
would much rather have your own
Community you go live in with a bunch of
anarchists and you guys created your own
guidelines you gotta land you're happy
with it they don't have to be anarchists
I mean it doesn't here's the thing do
you regard if they're not answering hold
on let me if if one of them is uh if one
of them is ambitious and says look I
have Ambitions in an anarchy system that
guy's eventually going to go and say
here's what I think we should be doing
and if that guy's got better ideas than
yours or is better at selling it than
you then eventually it's going to
convert into a different kind of a
government when you're done not not
necessarily because I don't think that
doesn't make any sense I'd love to hear
it yeah
better ideas are not the ones that
always went out as prohibition
demonstrated because then we repealed it
several years later there's many
examples of the markets where bad ideas
work for a temporary period than they're
rejected but let me just speak to your
point earlier do you if the Chinese
government right now passed the law that
said everyone has to wear orange all the
time would you regard those laws as
valid if China did one if if China
passed the law an edict that said
everyone everyone on Earth has to wear
orange would you find that as legitimate
it'd be weird that's not what I asked
you would you regard as legitimate would
you start wearing orange no why not
because it all look Dutch
is that true they were Orange in Holland
I wouldn't I wouldn't word it's why I'm
not living there right but why why
wouldn't you wear it
it's it's I like my choices okay but do
you regard their that law as legitimate
or not no okay so all anarchism says is
that it regards Washington's laws as
legitimate as those of Beijing you can
say that all you want all I'm thinking
of you is you and I will you shoot this
is anarchy but you should say that
that's great but to to think that this
is at the top level uh you know so so if
I ask you those questions and then I say
well what do you think about what's
going on with Ukraine and what's I'm not
educated enough to come down okay but
you're from there yeah but I'm an
American myself I understand that but
you're from there yeah but I left when I
was a year and a half I don't remember
anything I'm more like I speak Russian
okay I get that but you have these ideas
of Anarchy in a situation like Anarchy
What should happen over there well we're
not there right now for us to give that
opinion then then your argument loses
weight because it can only carry that
argument can only be sold in low-level
conversations not at high level
conversations a conversation that
carries weight and momentum is is is has
got enough backing to say it would work
if right now let's just say the world
was ran this way here's what would
happen between Russia and Ukraine leave
them alone okay then Ukraine would
become Russia well that's their business
that's not it at all my point is I think
it's important when someone gets on a
mic to come at it from an informed
perspective and I think just because an
issue is very popular in the news that
does not mean that it's uh are you are
you going to let me finish or not that
that's not I'm shaking my head doesn't
mean you can't finish fine it doesn't
mean that I have to have an opinion on
every single issue and I think a big
problem in our culture is that everyone
feels to have an opinion on every single
concern I'm not a Ukrainian I'm not in
Eastern Europe I've never stepped foot
there since I was one and a half so I
don't I agree with you I don't know how
Anarchist principles would happen in the
middle of a war between Russia and
Ukraine I don't know who the good guys
are then it's listen then it's so then
it's a good conversation to have you
know to go in on shows and all this
other stuff but it's it doesn't carry
enough weight on its own to rule and to
have a country around it that's kind of
what you're saying but it's not I'm
saying it wouldn't be a country it's a
relationship so number one and second of
all hold on I don't think that if the
U.S was Communist fascist liberal
conservative Progressive I don't think
any of those would inform the question
of what should the U.S do vis-a-vis the
Ukraine and Russia it's not a function
of what government we have what the
right thing to do is over there so so do
you have a vision with Anarchy I was
just going to ask that question what's
your vision with Anarchy like in an
ideal world there's no ideal world
that's the problem it's not a utopian
system what energy what's your vision
what's your vision my vision is a
situation where more people are
responsible for their own lives which we
have today
I said more people okay more people are
response I don't think we have that
today at all
um more people responsible for their own
lives there's less of a Reliance on
corporate news sources there's less
respect for the University system and
there's an increasing amount of absolute
contempt if not levels of hatred toward
government and government officials I
think we have all of those that we're
making progress on today out of them I
don't agree I I would easily sell it to
you I think uh Biden will go down in the
history books at least out of all the
presidents that we've had as the guy
that drove more homeschooling than any
other president
that we're making progress well that was
Trump that was covid it's not Trump it's
coveted it's not either of them but but
it's it's covet Biden because of what's
going on with you know pushing these
education and even the scientists I
would also say was the spokesperson to
drive people to consider saying I'm
either going to do private school I'm
either going to leave the state or I'm
going to do homeschooling I think it's a
combination of covet Biden DeSantis
together are driving up so that's true
that's progress next one the data that's
coming out that says in K through 12
schools 99 of Health teachers gave money
to the Democratic party 97 of English
teachers gave money to a Democratic
party and 87 out of a hundred uh Math
and Science teachers gave their money to
democratic party that means they got a
monopoly on that mindset that they're
teaching the kids and for every 13
Professor or 12th Professor that's a
Democrat one of them is a republican so
these numbers are coming out and people
are saying that's not cool so you're
either going to create a university or
I'm going to do online schooling I don't
even want my kids to go to college why
would I want to send my kids to college
people are making decisions we're making
progress and then social media you know
mainstream media I think it's very
obvious dude can you realize Jeff Zucker
got fired when when did Jeff sucker get
fired less than a year ago now what's
going on with Chris Licht where he's at
what's it what's going on with Chris
Lake he's either just got fired or he's
about to get fired right is he really
he's in he's in a deep you know he's not
in a good place if you pull up uh Chris
looked about to be fired so Main stream
media when Russell Brand goes on Bill
Maher and annihilates an MSNBC guy to
his face to the point where Bill Maher
gets uncomfortable we're making a lot of
progress when the number one guy that's
pushing back on mainstream media as a
former UFC not a UFC former fighter and
you know actor Fear Factor shows and
he's putting people in their place where
they can't go around you know saying hey
you better get vaccinated or else this
and all of a sudden people are saying
well I kind of like what he's talking
about what is this about Ivermectin I
think the progress is being made does
that mean that's we're leaning towards
Anarchy no it just means we're making
progress because if on a hundred
different issues if we wrote on a piece
of paper a an anarchy a Libertarian a
capitalist we may agree on 77 different
things or 78 different things or 82
different things
and then
you may disagree with you on four
different things
right liberty no no you know Dave Smith
no no games like this but you know what
there's a lot of things that we all want
to see have progress happen I think
we're making it do we want to have a big
government the way we do today no do we
want to see them printing money the way
they're doing today no I think they're
being exposed by both sides does that
give credibility to the Anarchy argument
I don't know about them I don't agree
with most of what you just said but let
me break down a few points where I
disagree with first of all I don't think
there's such a thing as big government
there's only government you approve of
any government that is big enough to
impose its will upon you will be
regarded by you as a big government and
if a government is so small that the
night Watchman state where you could
drown in a bathtub then it's not in a
position to impose any kind of weak Law
and Order regardless so there's no
coherent argument from anarchism number
one second I don't think it's at all
accurate and I'm friends with Joe I've
been on his show several times to regard
his amount of influence or amount how
much he's trusted is in any way
comparable to the New York Times or to
someone who's a law professor at Yale
these are to me still night and day I
don't think at all there is a view of
both sides if you mean like a Republican
and Democrat or liberal conservative
that they regard the state as a
legitimate there is no incentive and no
move in Washington let's just take it
from the conserve perspective to shrink
the size as a government by one dollar
you had Trump and two years of a
Republican and Congressional majority
there wasn't even an attempt to abolish
a single government agency let alone to
shrink the size of the government so
this idea that if you want to be kind of
have a Libertarian perspective and say
people are realizing government's too
big even if people are realizing this at
there's a DeSantis didn't shrink the
government at all I think he grew it
even faster than this predecessor so in
terms of you know 77 out of 100 things
if you and I both have the exact same
vision yeah of a house we buy what it
wants to look like and you want to sell
it and I want to move in we do not have
the same goal even if we have the same
vision yeah but in your world it's your
way or the highway Michael and and
that's very hard because the the the the
the way you sell your ideas our
conversation started off when you when I
asked you and you said well you know my
book is ranked number three on anarchism
on Amazon on Amazon and I'm making
progress great all I'm saying is
progress progress I didn't say it's
happening I'm giving you your point back
to you we're making progress Joe is
making progress Joe is not New York
Times we all know how big New York Times
is it's massive it's a behemoth but
we're making progress Elon Musk buying
Twitter it's progress all of these
things are progress we are making a lot
of progress towards the concept of
freedom of speech and people questioning
things they did in question before
because we're all collectively getting
smarter and saying
this [__] just doesn't make sense we're
not getting smarter we're getting more
informed I'm going to be pedantic
because that's important because I don't
think people are necessarily getting
smarter but we have more access to
information that is crucial and that's
what brought down the Soviet Union but
again I think you're kind of mixing up
several things you asked me earlier why
you know anarchism I'm not mixing up
anything I'm just telling you we're
making progress and just like you're
saying you you're uh uh the argument of
Anarchy is making progress I think
collectively more people are informed
today whatever definition you want to
give it informed or smarter more people
are informed today to realize
this [__] doesn't work we're unifying
when a Bill Maher
what are we talking about like Russell
Brand are you kidding me like when Bill
Maher and Russell Brandt and Joe Rogan
who endorsed Bernie Sanders a couple
years ago when they're coming up and
they're saying here's what we are
nobody in a million years could have
guessed this was going to happen Okay
the weirdest people are unified today
which I believe is Major progress but go
ahead you were asking earlier why
anarchism isn't more popular right and I
was giving you examples of a we're
making progress on that issue and one
concrete objective as opposed to my
personal feelings is the fact that the
book hit number three on Amazon so I
agree with you that we're making
progress in terms of both understanding
the nature of the state and the power
elite and also more specifically in
terms of promoting anarchism as an
ideology point being I'm not a utopian
right so even if I had for example a
magic wand and uh marijuana you are a
bit of utopian but Michael let me manage
something with you in a conversation
that's two hours
I may jump in and interrupt that's fine
if it makes you uncomfortable it's going
to happen 50 more times I understand if
you interrupt me I'm fully comfortable
you're not gonna offend me I'm a big boy
and I'm expecting you to be a big boy as
well I'm a very little boy perfect
that's totally fine okay yeah totally
fine I should be in my bed yeah you
should be in your bed and you chose to
be here I'm not a utopian and I do not
appreciate being called a utopian
because what I was about to say is if
all that happens is drugs become
legalized that's nowhere close to an
anarchist Society I'm not gonna say [__]
you that win doesn't count that's a huge
win if people aren't put in jail for
illegitimate reasons I will take that as
a goal I will accept it and celebrate it
the reason I wrote this book the white
pill was about the fall of the Soviet
Union the people in Russia Ukraine
Romania they're not living in some
Utopia they just things just got
significantly better for them and that
is important for those of us who fight
for Freedom you take the wins you can
get and you don't say oh well they still
have this law or they still have that
long no you go look things in our
lifetime in places that are not some
weird country that you can't find the
map moved fundamentally enormously in a
better Direction and they did it
relatively peacefully and relatively
easily and that to your point which I
agree with it is something that is
important for those of us to stay
motivated who fight for Freedom so that
this is why I think the anarchism
question in this context is a bit of a
distraction you don't have to believe in
anarchism to still fight for freedom and
to work with me and and other people
think like you and to take the wins when
you have them
yeah so so what I like about you know
competition is if your ideas are great
you can attract good people you'll track
money people come to you if you don't
you're gonna lose good people okay at
this table
his family's from Canada Tom doesn't
live in Canada okay right uh you were
born in Ukraine yes you don't live in
Ukraine correct here you live in Buffalo
New York that's right
by the way that's a joke he's in Austin
which is sunny which is sunny yes I was
born in Iran okay I live in U.S
Adam's family's from Israel well I'm
Jewish but my family is Ashkenazi Jews
from Russia
from Russia he grew up in Miami family
chose to come here okay if in a split
second U.S all of a sudden came up with
shitty ideas and it kept going the way
it was I don't think you have kids I got
four of them and I know you're a legacy
guy because you said that in the first
week like you you want to make an impact
you want to yeah so for me
if climate got bad and it was to the
point where I'm being forced to do
something I don't want to do I'm either
gonna run for office I'm either gonna
make money to have a platform I'm going
to speak up I'm gonna write a book like
you're saying here's what I believe in
and people have to read it and see where
it's at
or I'm gonna say you know what
I'm gonna go raise my kids in Singapore
I'm gonna go to Belize I'm gonna go
chill you know what here's what we're
going to be doing we're going to go to
XYZ
uh uh I think the world would be a very
weird place if we all 100 of us believed
in the same exact thing it would be
quite boring so a part of the fact that
you're talking about this you're forcing
the rest of us to question our arguments
and we're sitting there saying wow you
know what he he seems confident in this
he seems confident in that where's the
leak in the argument here so to wrap
this part up before we go into current
events rap I'm going to pull up this
I'll give you the final thoughts and
we'll go into current events so can you
pull up what our friends at uh uh uh uh
Chachi BT said about Anarchy this is
very important zoom in because some of
us can't okay there you go uh let's put
see the question first because it's
important Michael knows what is the
definition of Anarchy Anarchy is a
political philosophy or system that
advocates for the abolition of
government centralized Authority and
hierarchical organization of society
anarchists believe that individuals
should be free to govern themselves and
make decisions collectively without the
need for ruling class or state apparatus
Anarchy emphasizes the importance of the
individual Freedom Direct democracy or
volunteer Association as opposed to the
use of force or coercion it is important
to note that anarchy is not synonymous
with chaos or lawlessness as anarchists
often propose Alternative forms of
social organization and dispute
resolution right how do you feel you
like what he says are you okay with it I
am okay with that I'm just going to make
one more point I don't need a hundred
percent of people to agree with me at
all I don't have an opinion on how Macy
should have the refund policy I
understand that this is Macy's they're
not doing it right
honestly let's not go that far I'm not
going to go that far point being there's
lots of issues this is why I'm against
democracy there's lots of issues where
most of us shouldn't have an opinion
because it's not our business I have one
simple question
that everything you're saying is great
you know you're saying you know sort of
a low level conversation you know it
works
um but we live in on Earth we all have
to live in a country sure and we have to
live by which is a recent development
historical development that we live on
earth no that everyone is a member of
One country okay got it but sure we are
in modern times so I mean we're not
going back to Biblical times listen so
everything you're saying is great it's
amazing you know relationships police
everything I guess what country
is closest to even coming close to
implementing any of this anarchical
types of philosophy is there any country
that even comes close
and all and I'll ask this question but
I'll strike country so that you don't
pick on that right is there some place
or some group or something on Earth that
comes close
it not just comes close it is practiced
all the time whenever any people work
together voluntarily towards a common
goal so it's not a location it's not a
certain type of government so it's not
like you say um it's not like you're
going to say well America has an
anarchist government that's not how it
works wherever if you have peace freedom
and interrelationships with people on a
voluntary basis that is anarchist me put
into practice and where on Earth
whenever anyone uses Cuisine when
everyone does mathematics when everyone
people use Music internationally all
these things fashion these are all
examples of International historic
Energy Systems you're driving these guys
insane they want you to give them the
country so they can move there I don't
know why the hell out of here Michael
and you just want to [__] place
Israel Israel all right let's go let's
go into current events let's go into
criminals Tom give us an update on
what's going on with Silicon Valley and
Credit Suisse because a bunch of uh
bunch of stuff came out just yesterday
you saw their stock at the beginning the
Dow was down 600 and then it ended up a
couple hundred down what's going on with
the markets right now well speaking of
utopia
no uh overnight overnight it's very
interesting this can be summed up in one
chart do you have the chart that came
from Apollo
so this very interesting chart that
comes out assessing the balance sheet
risk of the banks yeah can you pop that
up a little
and the arrow up there that's uh toward
the left side is pointing to Silicon
Valley Bank everything to the right of
Silicon Valley Bank is actually more
risky and slightly worse off than the
Silicon Valley Bank oh my God balance
sheet was and then if you go all the way
to the left you've got at a score of 15
JP Morgan showing strength prudence and
you know probably you know the Utopia
banking experience sir because it's
risky so what overnight has happened is
that there is the realization that there
is a lot of risk at a lot of banks
that's happened overnight right before
the market closed First Republic
remember they said that was the other
bank everybody was concerned about it
has been downgraded and officially given
the rating as junk and Moody's came out
and said you're not pinning this on us
we're just going to say the whole sector
is downgraded and they downgraded the
entire sector to like this questionable
status and so right now literally Pat
what we are waiting for we are waiting
for the markets to show us Market
response to the stocks of the public
Banks and waiting for the other shoe to
drop because it's not just New York and
it's not just SVP and it's not just
First Republic It's Credit Suisse
yesterday morning coming out saying with
a stock price of 2.44 so they're down
the street from being delisted I mean
they're not far away I think it's 90
cents for so many days and something
they would be you know put on a
suspension and then ultimately delisted
so what's going on is there's a huge
amount of uncertainty Pat and there's
big amount of a certainty that no one
can have an opinion on can I show you a
poll real fast of course about what is
the Fed gonna do in the face of all this
madness and I put a poll on Twitter
yesterday so here's 326 votes do you
think and I asked a very just sensible
straightforward question okay Consumer
Price Index those inflation's about six
six and a half for the year still a
problem and with the svb collapse what
do you think Jerome Powell will do with
interest rates when he announces them
next week on the 21st 22nd half a point
as expected 20 a quarter point and be a
little more gentle or zero and then
revisit it on May 2nd which is the next
scheduled official meeting of the Fed
look how close it was 41 said he's gonna
you know just do a quarter point and 32
percent said a half a point 26 for most
of the life of the poll and this is 326
votes and these are public people not a
bunch of banking industry folks you know
it it stayed pretty even which means
everybody actually wasn't very sure so
we're gonna find out
um next week and we're watching and
waiting each day along with getting more
realization Pat that a lot of banks have
very weak balance sheets right now and
there's a lot of turmoil in the sector
but by the way when's the last time
Moody's downgraded an entire sector the
way they just yeah specifically crazy
right no and I'm not exaggerating that
is what they did yesterday before the
market closed they said okay we're
downgrading the sector when's the last
time is that a have you heard of that
before was it like a because it's 9 11
wasn't a sector like it wasn't like
you're gonna you know 911 was
so it makes you it makes you think yes
that I'm talking to the folks at Morgan
Stanley I'm like so what's going on he
says look you can raise 450 bibs in 12
months and not expect these Banks to go
through what they're going through right
now so but here's here's the question
the question becomes the following okay
Janet Yellen you guys build out those
you know however many people at Silicon
Valley Bank with above a quarter million
dollars FDIC so we're not bailing out to
uh uh uh Silicon Valley Bank we're
bailing out the uh the passators is what
we're doing okay fine no problem fail
can I get sold but we're helping the
people okay no problem great
how many more can you handle
one more right five more it's dominoes
10 more 20 more like you know you know I
had a friend of mine he started making
he was a the top interior designer in
Hollywood he was making 1.6 every year
and I'm his advisor he's sitting with me
I'm doing a needs analysis
I said so tell me uh your expenses
um how much you have in savings I I got
to run 500 000 okay how much you have in
401K zero how much you have in stocks
zero you only have a half a million
dollars yes how long have you been
making a million and a half about a
decade
I said what's your mortgage payment
mortgage payments 15 grand amount okay
what's your car payment
I got that SL 500 2 000 a month okay
great yeah where's the money going
where's the money going so watch what he
says he says I give my mom 10 grand a
month I give my dad 10 grand a month and
my mom asked me to help this sister out
my auntie I give her eight grand a month
and I give my dad's brother now eight
grand a month he was given his family
forty thousand dollars every month oh my
God you know what ended up happening
eventually the government failed well a
wait happens
once a way took place they're no longer
he's no longer he goes from 1.6 to 200
Grand a year okay yeah there's no more
Interiors to design it so I'm like so
what are you doing the houses are done
he's the government and he fails he had
to make four phone calls what are those
four phone calls his mom his dad the
sister the brother all that he was the
most hated man in the family I can't
believe you're doing this I'm 80 years
old here's a problem you can make one
company happy Silicon Valley Bank you
can make two signature maybe three dude
you can if this [__] hits the fan and 20
Banks smaller than Silicon Valley Bank
that secretly are sitting here saying
don't expose us and on top of that they
have a target of money being pulled out
how much did B if they just get be a
vacant 19 billion dollars teen billion
dollars in Silicon Valley Bank fails JP
Morgan says claims they got two million
two billion dollars how many more Banks
after seeing something like this are
saying babe let's take our money out if
this thing goes next level
right it's going to be a a scary scary
side Janet Yellen and Biden can see
Noble doing this with these guys very
soon they're gonna have to say no to
somebody and it's gonna hurt and the
rich will just get richer with these big
bangs you're all just going to go to
Wells they're going to go to the city
they're gonna go to Chase they're going
to Bank of America the interior is going
to be four big banks at that point the
interior designer should have just made
one phone call and then blamed it on
that one person this is mom's fault that
I can't pay the rest of you no it's the
wife honestly my wife wants to leave me
downgrading an entire sector I mean my
brother and sister and I get out of hand
my mom got Moody and downgraded all of
us but I've never seen Moody's downgrade
an entire industrial section it's going
to be in the Super Chat and tell us and
by the way if you know it put it in the
Super Chat and let us know because I
honestly don't recall there's the
problem of perception become reality
right if there's less of a belief that
these banks are stable that's going to
encourage more and more people to have a
run and then it becomes this kind of
dominance that's even worse that's even
worse and that was the Run they tried to
prevent you're you're correct they try
to they they wanted to prevent Anarchy
from happening and so what they said the
government usually does we're going to
protect we're going to pick the
depositors so please don't run on the
banks yeah so it's like they took 25
billion out there to prevent a trillion
and then it just becomes what a
self-fulfilling prophecy where it's just
like no this is happening and then I'm
glad my money's in crypto yeah that's
worked out well for the last year not
100 but yeah yeah but you can't be
serious Michael malice but if you're
glad your money's encrypted I am right
now of course I am yeah right now yeah
over the last year where it's gone down
70 I I bought low kept it I hoddled it
then it went down it's still there I'm
not gonna sell it when it goes down I
will tell you I will tell you and I'm
not a pro Bitcoin or an anti-bitcoin guy
like I'm not uh uh you know during the
entire hey can you do a uh sponsorship
for FTX we've never done it because I'm
not that's not my world so we've never
taken a sponsorship from a lot any
crypto guys and we've got a lot of uh
requests kind of like how you say I'm
not educated enough on the Ukraine to
give it I'm not a crypto guy to say hey
here's what we're doing with this but I
will tell you this if I am a Bitcoin guy
your argument right now is getting
stronger okay that's why Bitcoin went up
20 in a day went from 20 to 24 000 the
other day this is a very good time for
the pro Bitcoin folks to be selling what
they're selling there is a the only
challenge they have right now is the
following is uh my concern has always
been we've had Michael Sayler on a few
times and we've had a bunch of these
guys my only concerns always been that
uh these guys going to want to regulate
so the whole cbdc they come out there
try to regulate the crypto Community
what that's going to look like and
they're going to use this crisis
to say
you know what if this happens to crypto
what if this happens to this they're
going to figure out a way to regulate
that if they don't
I think Bitcoin is a good place to be if
they don't get their hands on it but
again we'll see what's going to happen
there all the D5 guys are out there
saying see told you yeah no by the way
exactly they should they should they
should say it this is a time to say your
argument if gold pops Peter Schiff
should come out and say I told you so I
told you so right it should it should be
able to my big concern is that at some
point maybe you're right that they're
gonna have to be like all right we gotta
stop the contagion bail it out and then
you have to get inflationary as a
consequence that's on top of the
inflation that's already happened and
what that ends up screwing over is the
poorest of the poor uh so that is really
my concern here uh we're on the same
page there 100 they they're going to
want to get their hands on it so let's
talk a little bit about reparations San
Francisco I'm sure you're a big
supporter of this so San Francisco
to consider five million reparation
check for black citizens uh and it's
it's actually they're getting pretty
close to it uh are considering a draft
plan for reparation package that would
pay five million dollars lump sum
payments to eligible black residents in
addition to eliminating personal debt
and tax burdens and providing guaranteed
annual income of at least 97
97 thousand dollars
for 250 years
to an under under
undermined number of blacks guys I'm a
little bit flabbergasted let me read
that one more time burdens and providing
guaranteed annual incomes of at least
ninety seven thousand dollars for 250
years
the plan also proposes allowing black
families to purchase homes in expensive
cities for just a dollar
critics have slammed the proposal as
financially impossible with one estimate
suggesting it could it could cost the
city roughly 50 billion dollars and
another suggesting that each non-black
family in the city would have to pay at
least six hundred thousand dollars
however proponents argued that five
million dollars figure is actually low
when considering the harm caused to
black community the state of California
is also considered its own reparations
proposal that would cut 360
000 checks for every eligible black
citizens so the state of California can
I point something out sorry yesterday I
was reading and it's very interesting
when did California abolish slavery in
California they never had slavery that's
correct that's a trick question and then
I look back at all the other states that
actually had legalized slavery
Massachusetts Connecticut it was really
shocking California has never had
slavery so even going back into
California history to say well at this
point we really feel the state you know
was was not acting and had done this and
had these laws no so how does the state
offer reparations for something that
actually historically it never actually
did so you're thinking in 2022 it's 2023
and it's not reparations for slavery
it's reparations for racism so they're
talking about California had like
discrimination would they have those
Covenant Clauses in a contract like if I
sold you a house above Dianne Feinstein
Michael Huffington when they ran against
each other I think it was in 94. it
turned out they had a house they had a
clause that says I will never in
perpetuity sell this house to an
African-American and people ignore them
but they're still in the books so this
is paying for all of that um and the
point is it's never going to and and the
point of reparations right Pat you
burned down my house you give me the
value of my house and some cost you know
suffering then it's I have reparations I
might I'm restored back to zero the
point of reparations is once it's
resolved you move on but does anyone
seriously think that if this actually
happens that's like okay racism is done
and we're gonna move on to society and
people are gonna stop complaining about
racism California of course not I'm in
favor of this because the faster
California gets driven into the ground
and the more of a kind of a
understanding that you know government
is just basically a Shakedown system the
better will be for everyone
but how does it work because it's San
Francisco so it's a city so it's not the
state right so they'll figure it out oh
they'll figure it out yeah they just try
to ban 3D printers in all of California
because there the law says I don't know
if they passed it yet but if any object
is used primarily or largely to 3D print
guns it's going to be uh uh they're
trying to ban it in California
can you can you find that article yeah
look up 3D printing it's right there I
just saw it Go the fourth one yeah
California passes new three the uh
that's 26 that's an older one yeah if
you can find a newer one it was just in
the last couple of weeks
pretty wild to be thinking about this
five million dollars so you know what it
makes me think about when I was talking
to Roland Martin and Roland said I grew
up in this community and I'm okay and
what happened I left why'd you leave the
community everybody left
I don't understand if you really want to
help the community why are you leaving
the community well because everybody
else left
so anyways he'll respond to this on
Twitter with some kind of a Lincoln and
file and I like it when he does it
because it allows me to go and look up a
few other things
but uh
what's gonna happen
if they can buy expensive homes for a
dollar
okay so you mean to tell me they can go
buy homes expensive homes at a dollar
and they're going to get 5 million n97
Grand over how many years 250 250 years
man if they're gonna lift 250 years
that's respect right but no no not
necessarily if inflation like five years
97 000 is gonna be worth like a soda
yeah
but but if you think about that then
here's a perfect case study for people
that are going to say well I can't
believe you if people if they do this
you're actually right if they do this
just to see what happens as a case study
it's a great case study for everybody
else
let's see what happens I'm actually
really curious what happens oh yeah go
for it do it give them the money let's
move forward let's see what happens to
San Francisco let's see if San Francisco
becomes a better City let's see if it
becomes more vibrant let's see if more
business owners want to move to San
Francisco if it does then guess what we
officially have a case study if it
doesn't you also officially have a case
study that it doesn't work I I think we
maybe have some I agree with that and I
think we have some Mini case studies out
there when you take a look at Mega Lotto
winners and what they do they
effectively allow their relatives to buy
a house for a dollar because they just
give it to them and when you take a look
at also athletes of all diversities and
all backgrounds you take an athlete
that's suddenly given this monstrous
contract when they get drafted by the
NBA and the NFL remember hockey and
baseball you have this rookie contract
that goes five years as you know Pat but
then you've got the sports where you
just walk in the door and you've won the
lotto right because you're one of the
top three kids coming out of uh college
and there you go and then you buy a
house for your mom and you give a car to
your brother and you give house to your
sister go take a look at the condition
of those assets and go take a look how
they care for them I'm telling you we
have many cases we have little mini case
studies that follow exactly what you're
showing people will not take care of it
I want to see it though
it works I want to see we figured it out
let me actually we have some community
in the house they say right here can I
say some more things the Chinese were
enormously oppressed in in California so
they're going to be next on this list
and they've I would they have more of a
reason historically with with California
than the African-Americans do so
reparations for them as well why am I
wrong what a noble requests does it not
make more sense for them sure there were
all this laws that was my question is
the slippery slope effective here
because right here it says why don't you
throw Iranians in there there you go
used to live in California go there for
vacation now I live in Florida I think
we should figure something out there
where's your Iran is only Americans know
about oppression if right if you watch
the corporate press you and I our
families if you don't know how to
impression
nothing happens no one left the elevator
very healthy upbringing you know it was
nice
just clear your throat real loud and go
for it rose water ice cream
thank you
what
it's a slippery slope effect so it says
it's going to cause the city roughly 50
billion dollars so let's say you know
you're a white guy you're an Asian guy
you're a Latin guy whatever you're
Iranian guy and you're like yeah all
right cool I agree maybe this is
something they should do let's you know
make right the sins of our forefathers
all right so let's say you do agree with
this okay great but by the way part of
this is each non-black family in the
city would have to pay at least six
hundred thousand dollars so hold on so
as a white guy all right maybe you can
make the argument all right well you're
not black you're you're forefathers were
maybe the oppressors all right it's time
for you to pay all right well now the
Mexicans gotta pay though the Asians got
to pay the Native Americans got to pay
like where does it end like how do you
determine who ends up paying so if it's
only if it's all non-black residents so
now we're all paying so my family just
moved here four years ago or 40 years
ago from Mexico I have to pay for some
it's just like where does this end
politics isn't about logic or reason
it's about power
uh that is kind of central to Anarchist
thoughts so what you're saying makes
logical sense but again this isn't even
about reparations in the sense of
reparations of making people whole this
is simply a basically a cash grab and a
way to kind of get a voting block uh in
place in perpetuity quite obviously but
wow if you're going for a voting block
you already have the vote it's this is
liberal cities it gets sentenced this
also appeals to Karen because white
liberal women Love Stuff Am I Wrong Love
Stuff let me tell you Karen I'm gonna
tell you right now I'm telling you right
now Adam I want to see this happen oh
yes I'm forwarded as well I want to see
it happen and you know who else I want
to see duplicate this New York City this
is oh do it I want I want San Fran to do
it New York City to do it Chicago to do
it LA to do it do it let's see what
happens this is why I donated money to
John fetterman I want to see I want and
he's my candidate for president I want
to see this happen the faster the Senate
becomes Arkham Asylum the better it is
forever
there's a part of it that's funny but
there's a part of it that honestly for
me uh we have a relative and I'll tell
you what this guy was a very prominent
figure on TV okay very in the Persian
community and at the tail end of his
career he had a stroke and the family
was okay with people coming and visiting
him and there's no way he would ever
want people to come and see him in a
condition like that it was horrible if
you know what I'm talking about and the
sun was not okay with this like this is
not cool for this to be happening I'm
totally I can't say anything I'm a
nobody in the family to say hey guys
what are you doing here they have to
make the decision if something like that
happened to you and I and if my wife put
me into public I would be
I'd be waiting for her in heaven
for her to show up and say what were you
thinking allow me to be in public
fetterman's family and Democrats to just
put him up front like that to say well
he's great he's this he's that that's a
form of abuse what they did to that guy
he could have quit at any time you're
removing agency from him he has Aphasia
he's not literally like Terry Shiva
brain dead yeah and this guy's entire
life has been seeking political power
this is the monkey's paw right it's like
you have a Genie's wish it's like I wish
I was sitting here it's like all right
but it's gonna cost you like I don't
care and now I'm hoping for the day when
some on the senate floor when his head
just explodes and covers 99 other
senders with brain Parts blood and skull
bed you would want to see that oh
desperately well you are an anarchist
there you go I'm an American every
American worth his salt wants to see a
senator's head just like JFK head
explode out of nowhere you just took it
to a whole different level your game
just went to a whole different level
okay let's talk about something else
let's talk about something else let's
talk about this let's talk about a
little bit of a I don't know if you
heard of this guy
um they both live in from this one state
called Florida one guy's name is Ron the
other one is Donald I don't know if
you're following yes
very competitive very competitive
so CNN Paul Michael so obviously these
guys know what they're talking about so
CNN poll uh most Republicans care more
about picking the 2024 GOP nominee who
agrees with them on issues than one who
can beat Biden okay so this poll shows
that only 30 percent of Republicans and
Republican leaning Independents believe
that the country's best days are still
ahead of it this represents a
significant shift from 2019 when 70 70
77 of Republicans were optimistic when
asked about the 2024 GOP nomination 59
of Republicans prioritize a candidate
who agrees with their views on major
issues over one who has strong chance of
beating President Biden the poll also
shows that 38 of Republicans view
increasing racial ethnic and National
diversity as a threat which is twice as
high as four years ago additionally 78
believe that society's values on sexual
orientation and gender identity are
changing for the worse and 79 think that
the government is trying to do too many
things that should be left to
individuals and businesses what do you
think about this I think the reasons
people give for why they vote the way
they do are almost never the actual
reasons right no one says I voted for
the better looking person I voted for
the taller person but they're going to
have a rationalization after the fact
that like oh I like him more for the
issues or I like his career kind of like
the Kennedy thing you were talking about
right exactly so I think when people are
asked what you're looking for it's not
necessarily what they're actually going
to do in the voting booth number one
number two is uh I don't think Trump has
a very good shot uh pun intended because
as soon as they start talking about the
factory stuff especially with the base
as soon as you start talking about his
Staffing decisions uh it's going to look
pretty bad for him and I also think that
there is enough in um impetus on the
Democratic side for him to be either
kind of
um charged with some kind of crimes
because I think they're better you think
so if I'm an attorney general and I have
the possibility of Prosecuting a former
president that's going to catapult me a
state attorney general General to some
national Fame and history books so the
incentives are very much there for uh
you know Democratic party operatives to
push him as far as they can why wouldn't
they no when you say you don't think
he's got a shot
um Define that meaning he has a great
shot of winning the Republican primary I
think general election I don't think he
has to go to shot the primary how could
you possibly say that he was 60 in the
seat he's gonna tell you if you don't
stop interrupt stop interrupting me
Michael malice CPAC is irrelevant as you
know because if you last see pack what
it was at this point in
2016 I don't think Trump's name was even
there uh or maybe he was because he just
spoken number one number two is he's
going to have an issue with fundraising
because now the it's he's become so
radioactive that if I'm a big
businessman and I'm giving him money
it's going to be a problem for me and my
customers because all the Press is going
to be on top of it uh there's going to
be enormous uh amount of there's a space
now if I am Facebook or am I some or CNN
or Fox for me to say no to his ads
because now it's been established that
this guy fomented Insurrection I don't
believe that's true at all but that is
the argument so it's easy for me as a
corporation who's going to be almost
always left the center to be like oh I
can't take your money because you're not
a patriot so on and so forth so he has a
lot more stacked against him now than he
did even in 2016. so let me go to a
story let me go to a story and then you
guys can continue with this so maybe
there is uh some an event that could
take place that could help him out
here's what it is Donald Trump's truth
social cut staff as hispack languishes
this is a Bloomberg story Trump and
Trump media and Technology Group the
parent company of Truth social has laid
off about half a dozen people
including senior members of its rank
such as the chief technology officer
which by the way that's in the
technology company yeah that's like
number one above everybody else William
B.J Lawson it's like you wake up in the
morning and fire your own heart that's
that's top right there yeah the the
company done yeah the company is that's
actually a good joke Tom that's two in a
row okay so the company estimates it can
find it can fund operations through
September at present spending levels
Trump media Executives were once
optimistic about the advertising Revenue
through social could generate but the
reality of launching an advertising
business has proved more complicated
through social monthly web and desktop
visits reached a high of 11.5 million in
in visitors in August uh 2022 but I've
seen a decline holy moly this is a real
number to 5.7 million in February so 11
and a half million to 5.7 is a little
over 50 that's 51 so here's what I think
and I want to get your thoughts and you
guys can talk about this this could help
them out why here's why
how long has he been free to post on
Facebook Twitter for a while Instagram
right but he hasn't okay why
he's trying to drive value to truth
social SPAC money all these people your
friends they put up money here's five
millimeters 10 million years 50 million
whatever the numbers right you're
raising a spec it's a very very risky
thing and it's probably the worst time
ever
that they had a spec possibly the worst
time ever when they did the SPAC at the
tail end of a peak of spax when all
these guys were doing specs back specs
we almost did a spat time for 400
million dollars you remember that last
minute we had a meeting we decided we're
not doing it but we were like all the
way in to decision on a zoom nope we're
moving on we didn't do it remember this
point for those of you listening yeah it
was some profitable company that had
been profitable for many years
yeah we weren't trying to go out and be
in public company just because we were a
profitable company
and even we decided no everybody we
called they said if you would have done
it five years ago yes this is the worst
time to do specs so if truth goes under
now he's not fully committed to posting
stuff on truth so he's going to be
active on what Twitter Facebook so maybe
truth social going out of business could
actually help us campaign I agree
completely because the reason people
like Trump and what I like the most
about him is because both his foes and
his friends every morning would wake up
and be like what is this [__]
tweeting about now right like I I could
the fact that when you had the Democrats
go into a military base overseas and he
pulled their permission slips and they
just circled the bus around and then
kind of get off the bus that was the
funniest [__] ever so him on Twitter was
what got him the presidency it was
integral to uh him getting the
nomination and getting the presidency
and they would behoove his campaign to
have him back on it despite all the
people who like take his phone away from
him that said he hasn't been on Fox
since in months uh the all like the
vascular conservative estab media
establishment has turned their backs on
him and he's not like fresh like he was
in 2015 when no one seemed anything like
him before I think it's gonna be very
hard for him to regain that fire that he
had now almost a decade ago I can't
believe you guys think this is actually
a good look for him I I hear what you're
coming from because if you want to win a
national election you're going to want
to be on all the major social media
platforms you're going to want to be on
Twitter you're going to be on YouTube
now you have a megaphone you have to but
there's a reason there's a reason he's
not using it right now because he's
doubling down on his back truth social I
would argue that the worst thing to ever
happen to Donald Trump on a social media
situation is Elon Musk taking over
Twitter okay because Elon Musk has
basically enabled Twitter to be a free
speech platform that was the whole point
of true social so the whole marketing
agenda was like this is a free speech
platform come join us this is where it
is all it has turned out to be is a
right-wing Echo chamber I don't know any
moderate or even liberal that's even
going close or even construction look at
Tom just pointed at himself he's like I
don't go there so the last thing that
Donald Trump I mean Donald Trump's got
you might some may argue that he's got
thin skin some may argue in order to
make it to where he's at he has to have
thick skin we don't know what exact type
of skin he has it's orange it's orange
we know that but the last thing that he
wants to be labeled is a loser but he
okay and you're about to say that he is
a loser I would argue you know he's won
a bunch more than he's lost but lately
he's been losing but
I don't think this is a good look for
his brand so what's his brand whether
it's Trump hotels Trump casinos Trump
Stakes Trump's Waters a lot of these
businesses have failed so now you're
telling me the one business Michael the
one business you've been working on
since you lost the election truth social
is now gonna fail tell me that how that
empowers him to be the president United
States again well I don't see it I don't
think truth Central as he called the
truth Central is going to be uh Central
to his brand or his identity I think
he's riding on I was the former
president I'm the one who could take on
Biden I had results in the past I'm
gonna have results in the future what
Maga people don't appreciate is that his
last year in the white house he took L
after L after L after L it was the
entire year of else it wasn't and the
fact that if you even if you regard the
election as having been stolen the fact
that they were able to drag this carcass
across the Finish Line how if he
couldn't stop that in 2020 with the
power of the White House behind him how
is he going to stop that in 2024 with
the power of the White House again
against him now you could argue that
whoever they put up if they're going to
take it he doesn't have a chance that's
a okay I can grab my head around that
argument but that's not a good argument
for Trump specifically as opposed to
someone who's won one could also argue
without covet Trump would have beat
Biden but I think a lot of these Maga
people think that no matter what
happened it would have been stolen from
him
yeah well we've seen what's happened
with the fox lawsuit with Dominion
if you're trying to talk to some
supporters that's their that's where
they are but so I guess as an odds
perspective I love coming getting the
odds like this wouldn't a hundred
percent hurt him it wouldn't 100 enable
him like give me the the odds of why you
think this would be good versus bad I
think this would be a bad look for his
yes food social respects I think you
were talking about two different things
you're talking about it would be an L on
his business Legacy and bother his ego I
think Pat was talking about something
else yeah I think both of you Michael
respectfully are very naive and they
have to accept it that you're very nice
and utopian
let me let me explain to you why here we
go okay here here's why here's why so
let's just say if
you were best friends and we've known
each other from high school okay we
always hung out we got along we've been
tight forever we have each other's back
okay
we're now you know you go through your
first divorce after being married for
seven years
and we get the call hey guys you guys
got a minute yeah what's up I got to
talk to you guys what's that Mary and I
are going through a divorce oh [__]
sorry bro 40 Grand a month yeah yeah so
kids did that no man it's just reached a
point it's just not gonna work out we're
going through a divorce trust me I'm
kind of dealing with it you guys mind if
we meet up somewhere tonight yeah no
problem we'll go meet up okay
so we feel bad for you
you six months later you meet Jackie
yo hey it's Jackie oh good to meet you
jack everything good yeah yeah what's up
for about three months but Jackie and I
met you know on Bumble and you know it
was a phenomenal we're happy for you man
everything good Michael yeah one
sentence my friend Jackie is currently
in the hospital and she's so caring she
called the cops on the nurses two days
ago so shout out to Jackie you're joking
no I'm not you want me to change your
name
so you're dating Jackie and you're happy
and then all of a sudden we come to your
second wedding okay and you're up there
you know you're doing what you're doing
me Tom and Adam walk to the side and
we're having a drink and we say good
guys over under what are your chances of
this one working Adam says I don't know
bro I think it's ten percent Tom says no
this one's gonna work out yeah he loves
her and 80 I'm like I don't know man I'm
kind of like a 30 Mark okay go all right
sounds good this one nine months later
give us a call and you say dude this
this chick's crazy she's a Karen she's
this she's in a hospital this is not
gonna work out right so what are you
doing I'm getting a divorce ASAP it's
just not gonna work out great no problem
the third time you call us for the
wedding our schedule is probably busy
okay what's the point here like ah he's
getting married again leave it alone you
never believed in me
we were friends since high school and
you're taking bets at my wedding [__]
you
that was high school dude you now you go
through women every time the clocks
change okay so so for those of you guys
that are upset saying Pat get to the
point here's the point the point is
how many stories are there with Stakes
with this with that no one gives a [__]
about truth social going out of business
Nobody Does this is not the first
divorce let me make my point and please
don't interrupt okay this is not the
first second or third I think
statistically
it'll take us a week two weeks to get
over it they'll take shots but what are
you gonna say he's filed this many
bankruptcies never worked he's in that
never work this guy's gonna be able to
get more eyeballs if this thing goes out
of business he goes on Twitter his first
tweet Michael
if it's the right tweet it'll be the
most liked tweet of all time ever ever
and he can create momentum if he gets
back there and quite frankly guess what
uh uh Elon Musk is not in a business of
running non-profits okay sure and he
joked the other day saying I'm
officially running the biggest nonprofit
of all time because they're not making
any money the revenues are down some
ludicrous crazy number that's down he's
going to sit there and say dude we kind
of need the prophets we'll take
memberships from Republicans from Magna
from whoever it is even from anarchists
common by membership we don't care who
you are I think truth social going out
of business is going to help us campaign
I I you're saying two contradictory
things so it will help his campaign in
the long term but in the short term it
is going to be a problem and this is
going to be an albatross right yeah and
it's different from the uh um
bankruptcies in the past no one cares
about Trump Stakes that happened in what
the 80s or 90s whatever was point is
this was their Mothership this is where
they went to and now it closed down they
get kicked out of their house they're
not going to like it because you people
make friends on social media you know
what I mean it's so it's it's gonna be
and the thing is yes it doesn't really
matter because it's not that big of a
deal but they're going to make it matter
because even Fox is going to a 24 7 be
like look another disaster from Trump
correct the TDs is going to be
everywhere and I think one thing you
gotta uh everything comes down to sort
of the news cycle if this does fail it'd
be better to fail sooner rather than
later and I think his spin is going to
make it worse because he's not gonna say
all right we tried our best then it
didn't work out he's gonna have some
cockamami excuse and that's what they're
gonna the left-leaning Democrats didn't
want this to happen they wanted to see
me fail by the way the only the only
recommendation I would give is I would
give the strategist that are working
closely with President Trump to have him
realize there's a different approach you
have to take as the favorite than as
they as yes what do you call it as the
underdog he's using the same strategy as
an underdog in 2015 you're it's not
going to work you have to take a very
different approach as a favorite because
he's coming across as a bully to
DeSantis right now and it's it's a it's
not attractive yeah but this goes back
to what I always say he's not gonna
change like everything he's done when we
when we've ever seen him change here's
what happened should he change should he
take some counsel of course we could
solve this problem
solve it all he has to do is sell truth
social to Kanye West and the problem is
solved yeah because everything he's done
with Kanye West has worked out really
well yeah
all his Arrangements this
one is specifically for you and I need I
need your insights yes sir
yes I will here we go
by the way Rob can we send what kind of
mattress do you have I have I have a
um I have a sponsor that's a mattress
company they feel like you've got to be
committed to them oh yeah I like it okay
all right but I need a twin and you twin
do you really yeah I have a guest room
do you need to I'm trying to make it
haunted no joke so you want like the you
got a girl you don't know you gotta stay
that's a guest room what do you mean
yeah when you're done you say go in the
guest room no no yes I said go on the
Uber your Anarchist like the wife sleeps
in a different room you're not thinking
like like you don't you don't bring the
girl over the house if you're married
are you crazy oh that's the mistress
comment you made it I got you I'm
following you I'm following you closely
Michael my apology Jackie's a big fan of
the show this is why after nine months
because of you Pat I apologize please
respond she's blowing up my phone right
now all right here we go here we go I
need your Insight on this one Mr Michael
malice Republicans knock Rhonda santis
after Florida Governor says help in
Ukraine
is not a vital U.S interest several
high-profile Republicans including
Senator Marco Rubio Nikki Haley Liz
Cheney and uh Lindsey Graham are pushing
back against Florida Governors around
the census argument that helping Ukraine
fend off Russia's invading forces isn't
a vital International interest and a
questioner sent by Fox News host Tucker
Carlson descent is declared that
becoming further entangled
let's say uh Jada Pinkett award yeah and
a territorial dispute between Ukraine
and Russia is not of vital interest to
the U.S and criticize the bite
Administration for Ukraine funding
Ukraine Rubio argued that Russia's end
goal is to overthrow the Ukrainian
government and rule the country and he
said the war should not be compared to
other conflicts or territorial disputes
settled with treaties or peace
agreements Haley accused DeSantis of
copying former president Donald Trump
stance on Ukraine and Cheney accused the
centers of weakness and forgetting the
lessons of Ronald Reagan Graham tweeted
that allowing Russia to succeed in uh
conquering Ukraine invites aggression by
China and Taiwan thoughts I have a
hashtag called limbs for Liz where
people who lost their arms and legs and
military service can send the
Prosthetics to Liz Cheney's house
because there's not enough corpses and
dismembered people for her taste she
needs a second house she needs a second
condo this woman is pure evil and
frankly my understanding is that she was
the model for Miss Piggy if you put a
picture them side by side you can't see
the difference
um I don't I think what DeSantis is
doing is he's running for the nomination
and I don't think Nikki Haley Liz Cheney
and Lindsey Graham between them see
that's identical uh if you have any am I
wrong that's offensive Michael why
because it's Haram
um I don't think between the three of
them they have any kind of clout with
the Republican base I think the
Republican base has become increasingly
radicalized and I think a year from now
when you're in New Hampshire and Iowa to
still be supporting pumping more money
to Ukraine is going to be extremely
unpopular with the Republican base
whether that's a good thing or not Adam
yeah I think what we're getting is a
little insight into Ron desantis's uh
mindset if if he were to run on a uh for
presidency which we all expect him to do
he's it could be as early as may I think
is when after the Florida
um
government situation kind of um
dissipates but he he's sort of cueing to
the base hey this is where I stand on
this and he's drawing a strong
delineation between what Biden stands
for which is obviously doubling down on
Ukraine he's saying quadrupling and all
that he sent every one of you know who
was the latest person that he sent over
to Ukraine it was uh
he sent Janet Yellen and then he sent um
Merrick Garland I believe to Ukraine
basically he's doubling down to Ukraine
he's basically saying this is the
difference between me and Joe Biden and
in the if that is who ends up running
against if he does get the nomination
he's sort of giving uh a heads up this
is where I stand and here's why this is
smart because the big Whispering
campaign coming out of trump and
maggoworld is that DeSantis is a closet
neocon when he was in Congress he's
basically another you know uh um uh
George W bush and there's a big concern
that he's a wolf in sheep's clothing and
that once he gets into office he's just
going to be a product of the military
industrial complex and just push for war
something that Trump uh from their
perspective did not do so this is a
great way for him to get ahead of that
criticism and be like I know you're
worried that I'm another war hawk like
you get year after year with Republicans
but I'm really different and I'm not
going to be like what you're fearing I'm
going to be
I think I agree with that to a certain
extent it's really early and that's what
I every time I see these things here I
just bang around in my head it's just
like okay next it's really early you
know Nikki Haley has her motivations
clearly Lindsey Graham and Liz Cheney
you know they've got their motivations
and I think also
the classic technique you know of
whenever you have somebody emerging is
to start picking up Mitt Romney didn't
have the entire Republican party behind
him when he was emerging people were
picking at him I think you know it's
power brokering it's it's people like
Nikki Haley she's competing with him
she's a competitor just call it she's
competing for the Republican nomination
so she's a hard-nosed competitor so
we're not surprised about her yeah check
and everybody else has got their
um he's got their motivations and he is
the emerging front runner and I think a
lot of people are trying to shift the
power where they want it to be you know
you know one of the things that I think
you is a is a sign of a guy that's got
the chances of winning is you have to
take a hard position yeah and get a ton
of backlash and still stand firm and
then the market says wow good for him
and then the argument creates momentum
kind of like what you're doing right so
think about like your argument of no let
me tell you
okay well maybe he's got a point now you
got to have your Tipping Point for that
argument to really go but I think I
think the scientist has to take this
position
um I think it favors him now whether
people right like it or not it is what
it is there's a lot of people right now
that are kind of sitting there that were
all pro Ukraine Let's help these guys
out change the flag colors on my Twitter
profile now it's like I don't know about
all this money that we're spending and
we're experienced in America so I think
it could help them out position wise I'm
not sure the level of credibility with
the other guys you you don't want to be
the group of 18 people that agree
disagree with the one guy right because
you're the market differentiate like why
why am I buying RC Cola because I'm
cheaper there's got to be something
better though okay there's got to be
something I'm a Dr Pepper guy there's
gotta be something that distinguishes me
from the other from the from the other
brands uh um and I think it's um I think
for the this for the most this is the
most extreme Time In Our Lifetime where
there is a disconnect between a party
and its base specifically between
Republican party the Republican base I
don't think we've ever seen anything
like it the Animus that the Republican
base has towards the Republican Party
can I say one more thing about this uh
do that and then I want to go to this
next just real quick because they keep
using the word of national interest this
is not uh DeSantis says specifically
this is helping Ukraine does not fend
off
um evading forces is it of national
interest one could argue yes this is not
of national interest but this is of our
International interests right so
obviously NATO is an International
Alliance that that is there to protect
typically Europe
against Russia's Invasion and one could
argue that all right if we allow this to
happen what's next what's the slippery
slope that happens with Poland or
Finland and we've seen that Finland and
Norway or whoever it is just recently
been introduced to to Nato
um and then then you hear you have here
is uh Lindsey Graham you've been
tweeting that allowing Russia to succeed
in conquering Ukraine speaking of
slippery slope now invites China to
invade Taiwan so where does it end if
U.S doesn't draw the line on these types
of situations then where does it end
because at certain point then China is
going to even more so beyond Russia's
side so if you want to play
brinksmanship it's not going to be like
the good guys always win if you're
assuming that we're the good guys as we
just demonstrate in Afghanistan
yeah why not I completely understand on
that but so but at the end of the day
one can say that this is what I said a
couple uh weeks ago I think this is a
vital U.S interest to stand Pat on what
we believe in democracy you can't just
invade countries I think that's
something that we should whether it's
soft power Howard bar throwing money on
it that we should stand behind are you
realize this is my no not not not
whatsoever the one that you could always
argue is how much money how much money
can we be spending is it where do we
draw the line on that right now we're at
a hundred billion dollars are we willing
to commit another 100 billion dollars
how about a trillion dollars we spent
what a trillion dollars in Afghanistan
if not more we spent four trillion
[__] dollars in Iraq so one could
argue hey the money just doesn't at make
sense whatsoever but standing firm on on
what we believe in I think is there's no
amount of money that we can put behind
that would you regard it as somehow
wrong if Putin started targeting
American uh sources resources
like if you started bombing American
bases
well now he's in just somewhere would
you regard that as somehow illegitimate
what do you mean by illegitimate meaning
like okay it's not an act of War then
yes but the point being like would you
be surprised at a certain point If
You're Gonna Keep funding his opponent
we start becoming parties to this war
ourselves no question about it yeah yeah
so you're playing a very dangerous game
where you can it's easy to be like we're
the good guys we're for democracy you're
not going to do it but we're not going
to send troops at a certain point he's
like [__] you yeah that's going to be
very that's something I'm terrified I
totally understand and that's a great
argument but that the other the other
end of the of the spectrum is all right
do we just allow Putin to do whatever he
wants with no consequences and we don't
step up we're America I mean like the
world goes as America sort of goes like
if we don't step up if we don't lead who
leads that China Russia Iran like we
need to stand for something here I I
hear what you're saying but at a certain
point our the problem the Thatcher very
famously said the problem with socialism
is eventually run out of other people's
money we have limited resources and this
idea that we can fund Wars everywhere
across the world in perpetuity wherever
so-called democracy is threatened I
think flies that is the utopian
perspective and at a certain point we
have to be like all right this sucks
we're like North Korea is a great
example you know if I had my brothers
and talk about utopian if I had a magic
wand I would Liberate the North Korean
people we can't do that because the
military and and so on and many other uh
China's has their backing so yes I like
the idea of protecting liberalism in
whatever form it takes throughout the
world but at a certain point we're
making ourselves the targets and we're
going to have other 911s yeah I agree
and that's essentially my point is that
what amount of money are we willing to
commit to this I don't I think
speeches soft power saying what we
believe in that doesn't cost anything
and I think that's what we should be
doing I think it's fully in our right to
argue hey this is where else could this
money be used I I think that we need to
stand for what we believe in and not
invading Sovereign Nations I think is
sort of tantamount but what does
Stanford what we believe and mean that
can mean anything up to boots on the
ground
if I'm not sending troops am I really
standing for what I believe in if I'm
not you know putting lives in risk or
I'm just talking out of my ass at that
point right
you're saying that you have to send
troops or send if I really want to stand
for what I believe in Then I then
there's no price too high that happens
fall are you going to to the speech he
gave about the Americans uh will need to
send their sons and daughters no I'm
just going to his point that like look
listen if there's if we have to stand up
for what we let's make Putin it makes it
even easier if it's like Putin's like a
Hitler figure like like really just pure
evil and and the ukrainians
like labeling that are we are are you
comfortable always allocating no matter
how many resources we have to always
fighting dictators and at certain point
the answer is we can't we at a certain
point we're gonna run out of military
we're gonna run a Weaponry we're gonna
have people's patience too and that's
the big problem I agree with you I'm
saying that that's like no I know but
money shouldn't be the only situation
that we're looking at I agree we can't
just go down the rabbit hole of another
Afghanistan of trillions in Iraq let's
go to the next story let's go to the
next Story the santis administration
revokes Hyatt Regency Miami alcohol
license after it hosted a drag queen
Christmas this is an Insider story The
DeSantis Administration is revoking
their license
uh after the party with minors present
in the audience the state's business
department accused the Miami venue of
several violations including a
Prohibition prohibition of uh uh how do
you pronounce that word less less
vicious lascivious lascivious what is it
what does that even mean sexual okay
sexual exhibition before people younger
than 16 the department said performers
were wearing sexually suggesting
clothing and prosthetic female genitalia
as well as simulating masturbation
governor Republican Governor the
sentence of Florida supported the
license revocation revocation and his
press secretary said that sexually
explicit content is not appropriate to
display to children and doing so
violates Florida law equality Florida
and lgbtq rights organization said that
the sentence was selectively weaponizing
state agencies against businesses to
Target drag performances saying such
decisions should be left to the parents
yeah so uh the corporate press won't
discuss that's what the content of these
shows are it's literally uh two male
dancers in their like Speedos humping
each other on stage and it's if you look
up Jimbo tits in a box Jimbo's one of
these Queens I'm a big fan because drag
is transgressive and it's good art for
adults but he's performing with the
songs literally called tits in a box
with dancing around with his big tits in
a box and there's kids there who are
like five six or seven and one the
Queens was the queens were addressing
the children the audience as well
so yeah if you look at this this is not
appropriate for children but it's
perfectly appropriate as adult risque
entertainment no doubt but here's my
question five six seven-year-olds aren't
just getting in an Uber and showing up
by themselves
white liberals taking them there because
white liberal moms want to show their
dad how trans how Progressive they are
and they put a man in makeup and they
think it's the second coming so then
here's the question it's not appropriate
for children although it's hilarious but
isn't it the parents decision as to
what's appropriate for their kids or not
yeah I would never take my any of my
kids my nephew any of my to anything
like this but if Karen wants to take her
daughter to this event that's her
decision why would the government step
in and tell you what you can and do can
do with antithetical to what what we
stand honestly you can stop it it's it's
totally yeah Robert you're getting a
little excited would you be fine with
Karen taking her kids to a bar or
dispensary
well being
you can't be under 21 right to be in a
bar but that's what he that's what the
Santa's trying to do he's saying you
can't be under I think it was 18 to show
like this I don't know I thought the
whole premise of the Republican party
was limited government and being able to
do what you want to do again I'm not
defending that whatsoever I think it's
[__] absurd
isn't it the well it used to be but
isn't I don't know about limited
government you can call 21 for alcohol
and and things like that I don't think
yeah but that's not secular limited
government you're right but I don't
think that one really applies here
you're telling me that the Republicans
don't stand for The Limited number and
getting out of it how to get out of your
life in your bedroom like that no they
don't they don't no they don't but but
that was the whole premise no no no no
but they don't what are they where am I
getting that keep keep going where
you're going stay stay on the yard
because that is the argument the
argument of some people on the left will
be isn't the right the freedom of speech
and not censorship why are they
censoring this your argument is well
this is an eight same thing with a
dispensary can a Karen take their kid to
a dispensary and buy so so so are you
saying is there a law for age right now
where this is illegal was there a law
broken for this no I I'm not familiar
with exactly this can you find out if
Allah my point being it is not at all
crazy to me that there are mechanisms in
place where children are not exposed to
sexually explicit material yeah I think
there's a lot of historical culture they
use the phrase violation and they were
stating in age so I assume that the
Santa Administration was acting on
something that was precedent I'm
assuming go go back up the business has
21 days what go back up all the way up
yeah the business has 21 days to request
a hearing uh Beth a spokes of women for
the Department told Insider emergency
Hotel liquor license still on effect and
said that the hotel was reviewing the
complaint third party operator manages
the knights centers programming and
ticketing wildhood a third party
operator manages the night centers
programming and ticketing while the
hotel provides food and beverages
concessions Republican Governor said
widely considered to be in the mountain
presidential sexually yeah what I want
to know is what law was broken okay
because these are two different
conversations what laws I think it's
more like if you're going to be serving
out because he took the liquor license
he didn't put anyone in jail so I think
the premise is if you're going to have a
liquor license establishment you're not
allowed to have underage people but
that's not true though because when I go
to Armenian weddings trust me there's a
lot of liquor and there's plenty of kids
around but maybe those laws aren't being
enforced in those situations but one
more to your point uh we could all wrap
our heads around kids not being able to
go to strip clubs or to Chippendales
right doesn't mean they shouldn't exist
they should be banned so I think this is
just kind of more the same but in a gay
context
yeah and again I'm not I would never
take my nephew to anything like this
that's not for me but I'm just given the
counter argument where it's like okay
what's acceptable or not so if you go
back to that video it's like where do
you draw the line like let's say kids
want to go see a clown or you want to go
see a magician go back up go back up the
the First Amendment yeah write the
fundamental tenant the first amendment
is that the government should not punish
people simply because it disapproves of
the content their speech yet the
decision will harm a business simply
because it supported speech of
government speech to government doesn't
like right that legislation program
against someone including Florida has
targeted direct performances with you
know that this year Tennessee becomes
the first to ban adult performances
including drag okay but that's where I'm
going with it where I'm going with it is
the following here's where I'm going
with it
great
if you want to take the license away
rather than taking the license away do
what Tennessee does
ban adult performances including drag
from public spaces such as parks and
schools if you want to do that with kids
being present make that a law but if
it's not a law they didn't break a law
if they did break a lawn you revoke
their license fine it's a lot I don't
know if it's a law or not if it's not
and you do it then you give an argument
to the other side to come in and say
well isn't you aren't you doing this
aren't you doing that Oh I thought you
were for not censorship all this other
stuff first of all yesterday I'm talking
to um
uh Frank from uh gaze against groomers I
don't know if you're familiar with games
they do a very good job and and Frank
and I were trying to get a time he's the
executive director to get him on the
podcast I'm looking forward to having
the conversation with them uh uh for him
to give his perspective on how he feels
about this these guys do a very good job
and I want to learn more about them you
know
if it is a law
then you can prevent the kid you can you
can enforce it if it's not
parents are uncomfortable with you know
drag queens being shown to kids but then
your argument is well shouldn't the
parent have the decision the kid didn't
get an Uber go there it's the parent's
decision you want to take your kid and
watch a scary movie or something you
took to risk it says rated R except with
what Parental Guidance or PG-13 but if
you got parental guidance whatever you
can go watch the movie The Parent took
the risk this is a form of that is kind
of what you're saying but I think the
argument it's more like X though
that's what it's more like rated X where
you can't take a kid to porno I don't
think it's soft porn because I don't
think there's anything uh uh I don't
think it's soft I think this would
probably be considered rated R even nc17
is when they show you know two getting
naked and you know but I think this
isn't our thing that the parent took the
risk regardless of it regardless of it
trust me when I tell you this the
Santa's taking the position the people
who are saying I can't believe this he
was never gonna get their vote anyway so
he's not losing or gaining anybody there
but the people that were sitting there
that were for him who are parents with
kids they're like dude I don't care
whether it is or it's not I like the
fact that it's defending something like
this he got those people that will
support him which is that's the vote you
want anyways and this is I mean look
that's no secret that the Santa says his
his whole agenda is the war on the woke
this Florida is where woke comes to die
DeSantis is basically revealing his
playbook for 2024 okay
anything the trans I'm out on that
against it boom Ukraine we're getting
out of there he's revealing what he
stands for and he's delineating between
himself but Biden with Trump and he's
just
he's showing us who he is and by the way
I don't I don't think many people would
agree that they want young kids around
trans stuff I think there's going to be
over 50 majority they're going to
support this I think my only question is
isn't it up to the parents to make that
decision not the government
well I I think it depends on how
comfortable you are with what kids are
being allowed to see because at a
certain point we're gonna everyone would
agree that if you're giving a kid like
drugs or alcohol uh we're gonna take
that kid away from the parent on the
other hand if they're just showing them
you know always signing Philadelphia no
you know very few people are even that's
not appropriate for amazing show yes
very few people are going to say all
right let's call CPS or it's not a
Libertarian argument that's the
libertarian argument no I'm just
perspective so the question is what are
you comfortable with what maybe it's
different on a state-by-state basis the
difference is you're right that a
majority of people aren't for the trans
stuff with kids but this is constantly
being portrayed in the corporate press
as just simply anti-lgbt they're not
acknowledging or addressing the content
of these shows it's not a guide in
addressing some nice song and it's nice
wholesome family entertainment it's
explicitly sexually a suggested
performances and sexually explicit
material and that is very different from
how if you watch The View you're going
to perceive what's happening yeah by the
way again for me if you're campaigning
you you have to take some risks yes and
and the sentence is taking the right
risks watch two conversations he's in
which is exactly what you need to do if
you want to create momentum one you got
Republicans to vote against you and
disagree with you Rubio Haley you know
whatever Cheney yeah Ukraine phenomenal
you have one position that's a risk the
other one hey we're doing this to these
guys that's a risk who am I gaining the
millions of people that are also asking
why are we sending all this money to
Ukraine well we have a bank going out of
business here why are we having our kids
be exposed to transgender I'm sorry I'm
not good with this so I think he's
taking the right risks there is risks he
has to take it if I ask you right now
what's Nikki Haley's position give it to
me give me one risk Michael is taking
what's her position give me one risk
Marco Rubio's taking what's his position
give me one risk list Chinese taking
what's the position the only risk the
list chain you took is what
after the comments being made about her
father he turned against January 6th
that was a risk she took because she'll
never get mega but Liz Cheney is better
off today becoming a Democrat than
staying a you know what do you call a
rhino Republican I don't know where you
put it where she's at so yeah
that is also a risk but that's a big
risk she they thought Lincoln project
was going to be bigger than it actually
ended up becoming well not necessarily I
think she got crushed in her election
yeah the risk reward did not work out it
kind of did because we all know her name
she's very well positioned to get a book
deal to be a pundit if that's what
you're solving yeah you're right
being a congresswoman then it was a
horrible race yeah but I mean she's got
the Cheney money Cheney name she has
other paths to pass she wants to get her
Show on MSNBC she just signed that deal
locked in exactly for the view I would
like to do two business stories and then
we wrap up if that's okay with you guys
Tom Mark Zuckerberg on how to run a
company in 2023 this is a Wall Street
Journal story
uh uh Mark Zuckerberg has announced an
update vision for the company in a year
of efficiency focused on cutting costs
and improving productivity that this
comes after a year of slow growth and
economic uncertainty the company plans
to cut 10 000 jobs over multiple rounds
of layoffs while leaving an additional 5
000 open positions unfilled it will
eliminate middle management and flatten
its corporate hierarchy by converting
many managers into employees with no
supervisory responsibilities in other
words an anarchy low priority projects
will be canceled and internal tools will
be strengthened to help software
Engineers write code faster the company
will also pause new remote work
applications and requests to transfer to
another office through the first half of
the year as some employees have
performed better in person however
matter is committed to allowing both
remote and hybrid work Tom thoughts I I
found this to be like the death of a
Thousand Cuts he's pouring money into
this hole
um called the Ukraine war I I mean um
and um so he's doing that and then
they've laid off some people now wait a
minute we have to the year of efficiency
is just a year of job Cuts he's trying
to align what was this bloated cost with
the
economic reality the revenue to bring in
cutting 10 000 jobs and closing 5 000
open jobs it's he's basically he's
showing that this company has been
completely caught out and now he's
having to walk back and re-optimize and
he's not getting any number one and the
reason I'm going to do that he's not
getting any traction on the metaverse
but actually they had a pretty good Q4
that showed signs of light that with the
right number of folks they still are a
volcano of AD money which is good but
the the humorous part for me is pausing
new remote work applications so let's
read that pause new remote work
applications no one is getting
permission to work remote anymore and
then some employees have performed
better in person and then then to to
quell the Revolt before it happens
however we're committed to allowing both
remote and hybrid work so so I I think I
I think Mark is sort of an enigma
wrapped in a contradiction these days
Michael I I don't know that listen I'm
no Mark Zuckerberg he knows his business
in his company infinitely better than I
do but from my understanding of social
media and social media Dynamics I don't
know how you turn the ship around
because once some uh internet
um social media site is regarded as kind
of updated or you know Grandma it
becomes a lot harder to get the kids
which are what it's kind of like
cigarettes right you want that Young
Generation to kind of keep it going to
sustain it I've been on Facebook in a
couple of years I know for a lot I I got
I don't know Joe no if you go to use
Instagram or no I use Instagram
facebook.com Michael Miles you could see
my last post a couple years ago it
hasn't heard it hasn't hurt my my uh why
haven't you though what's your what's
your reason I I was it drove me crazy
that he changed this so I couldn't see
everyone's updates in a reverse
chronological order that you're gonna
curate my feed for me it's like this is
what I want I want to see everyone who I
follow you'll see all their posts how
many fans you have on Facebook right now
I have no idea I'm sure thousands uh can
you see the number
well you don't have a fan page that's
just your personal do you have a fan
page or no I don't have a fan page
Michael I think you ought to consider
having a fan page let somebody monitor
it not even you doing it have somebody
add your Clips only reason I'm saying
this if it's not important don't do it
you you are a brand that could generate
an additional 10 to 20 a month off of
Facebook if it's not it's important to
you don't worry about it but you'll blow
up on on Facebook and their monetization
is actually working effectively but good
point to say who's even using that right
that's kind of what you're right exactly
yeah and it's certainly not like
something that's regarded as a Cutting
Edge or hip or anything like that it's
really how do you do that it's very hard
yeah how do you do that how do you how
do you Tom the question becomes he makes
a good point how do you make it cool
again right because to me you know you
know how sometimes uh a parent screwed
up with the kids and they try to win the
kids over and they lower the standards
well guys moving forward you don't have
to make your bet thank you that you
didn't you didn't improve your situation
here right hey moving forward babe in
our relationship I will be more you know
XYZ no no you didn't make yourself more
attractive I I think there needs to be a
vision that's attractive to get a new
market Facebook is officially the
company that buys companies right before
they're about to blow up and that's the
brand yeah and you've talked about that
before but how do you make Facebook cool
again that's the trillion Auto question
because you know those little um you
know that they're on t-shirts and
everywhere and it shows Evolution where
you have the the primate and then he
slowly starts to stand up and then he's
walking well basically you can look at
social media like that and you've got
AOL then you have Friendster then you
get Myspace and you got Facebook I don't
think you go back I think once a new
generation decides that that is the
arcade social media has proven let me
say that as proven that once a
generation turns its back on the prior
and goes to forward that's it I mean ask
the people at Snapchat who are sitting
there every morning at church praying
for tick tock to be shut down United
States so that they have a chance to be
rejuvenated I don't think you turn it
around Pat and that's why you hearing
things like we're going to the I think
Mark knows it and that's why he doubled
down on the metaverse call it dumb call
it smart call it what you will but he's
doubling down because he needs a new
play and now they're coming out and
saying we're going to make this um open
format you know messaging platform with
interrelated uh relevance to the
messages okay so why don't you just say
you're trying to make a Twitter
competitor at some point and that's what
you're working on in the back room let
me I don't think you can turn back the
clock yeah yeah so so I think you can I
think you can and I think you believe
you can as well but but I think the the
gift Tom uh uh the gift of doing that
Mark doesn't have okay just like like
you know you know what true social needs
first of all they need a trump uh they
needed the uh Elon to not buy Twitter
that screwed up truth social the day he
bought Twitter it's over with right that
was game over yep sure but but take
Cheryl Sandberg outside of Facebook
what's Facebook nothing take look at the
names I'm about to tell you take Cheryl
Sandberg out it doesn't have the
valuation it has number two take who's
the guy that came from Napster what was
his name
take Sean Parker up what's the vision
Sean Parker was the vision okay Cheryl
Sandberg was the uh money ads the the
twins uh whatever the uh those guys were
the idea
uzuk is an operator and an Executor and
a driver that's what he'll do but he's
not that guy so I think he needs to find
the next give you a perfect idea most
people when you think about Fox News
you ask the average person Fox News
who's the founder of Fox News they're
going to think the guy that's the
founder of Fox News is who Murdoch no no
if you ask me Roger they have no idea
they have no idea no idea they have no
idea the guy's Australian what an
Australian accent Rupert Murdoch is an
Australian government an Australian
accent what took fate what took Fox to
be a behemoth was a guy named Roger else
okay you take Roger Els out it's not
going to happen the best thing Zuck
could do right now the best things I
could do right now is stop coming up
with ideas it's not your strength
go find the biggest badass innovator
creative that wants to prove a point
give him a fat salary with a big upside
let them come in rather than coming up
with ideas go find your Roger rails go
find your next Amber go find your next
recruit this is recruiting season I
think the approach he's taken is not
going to work out because he's not a
vision guy he's an Executor and by the
way zucks are very very hard to find
very very hard to find there's a reason
why he's worth what he's worth but he
can go find the other guys they're out
there I don't know a single person and
obviously that's a very bad metric for
saying something like this but I don't
want to put that caveat who's on the
metaverse or spends time exactly and mod
my friends are big influencers in very
many fields if I don't have one data
point to the contrary that says
something yeah yeah so anyway that's my
I may be wrong all I'm saying is go
recruit a guy like that you have plenty
of money and attract the platform to
give it to somebody and by the way that
guy becomes a savior just just 20 years
ago not even 20 years ago 197
1976 when did Apple get started 72 or 76
it's uh what year did Apple get started
1971 what year does it say 76 okay 1970
April fools 1976 pretty wild so they get
started 76 and an accidental millionaire
book comes out trashing good jobs right
and then what happens to him he gets
fired and then Apple's about to die
Scully the guy that he brings from Pepsi
ends up getting firing him right jobs
goes to uh home fries what do you call
it a Pixar and he sells Pixar to who
Disney then Apple comes in he starts
working the next computer yes so then
they come in then they bring him back
and then boom it takes off I think
Facebook
needs to go find
recruited Talent by the watch what
happened here yesterday it says 16 hours
ago U.S threatens band of tick tock
Chinese owner don't sell steaks okay
this is all over the place axios wrote
it NBC wrote it they wrote it if if and
this wasn't this isn't something that
was started by uh Biden Trump proposed
this and I don't know if you remember at
one point there's a bunch of people that
were going to buy it you know I don't
know what to come Twitter was I think
one there was a couple companies yeah
I'm gonna buy this guy uh tick tock
I I want to say it's not a bad buy but
for Facebook but I don't think it's a
good buy for Facebook because they
already got it it's Instagram I think
this is a very good buy
well I
I don't think it matters who owns Tick
Tock I think it matters what Tick Tock
is connected to and if Elon buys it
he'll find it'll be Tick Tock files and
you'll see everything if if they force
so he would pull it out of there Tom 100
look at what Vivek ramaswani's campaign
is right now you know what he wants to
do did you hear what he said yesterday
he said a lot of things I can you go to
Twitter real quick here's what he said
yesterday which I found very interesting
so you know what Vivek wants to do
here's what Vivek wants to do what vivec
tweeted yesterday this is the kind of
stuff that your your your life is on the
line so let me find this tweet here what
he said he says if you vote me in he
wants to do
to the U.S government what Twitter
Twitter Elon Musk did with Twitter files
I don't know if you know what I'm saying
they put up six feet under in two
seconds of course they would so but he
came out and he says I will be exposing
the FBI files of this files it's a very
uh uh you know what's the word utopian
yes I don't know he better not walk
through the kitchen at The Ambassador
Hotel yeah what are you talking about
look he is he's got guts he's got
audacity and I don't even mind right
there just says Elon Musk did at Twitter
as president I will release the state
action files federal government exposing
every instance where the feds pressured
companies to take constitutionally
prohibited actions I I like this this is
good but if if Elam buys Tick Tock
combine Tick Tock and Twitter I don't
know there's something attractive about
that but will Biden and his Camp allow
Tick Tock to be sold to Elon you know
that's not going to be happening they're
going to get in the way or whoever buys
it has to untangle it from all that yes
that word
it's Chris Rock's favorite word right
now so anyways I don't know what's going
to happen there but that was the one
story time I'll do the mortgage story
and I'll give down one too and we'll
wrap up
so page eight let's see here
uh mortgage demand Rises despite
volatile interest rates this is a CNBC
story mortgage demand increase for the
second week in a row with the total
application volume Rising by six and a
half percent compared to the previous
week according to Mortgage Bankers
Association despite mortgage rates being
higher mortgage applications to purchase
a home increase by seven percent for the
weekend homeowners home buyers concerned
rates will continue to rise however
applications to refinance a home were uh
seven uh 74 lower than a year ago it's a
big number the average contract rate
for 30-year fixed mortgage with
conforming loan balances decreased to
6.71 from 6.79 that's not a big number
but rates were large largely largely
higher for most of the week before
dropping sharply on Friday due to news
of Silicon Valley bank failure so is
this like Tom just a small little
movement here is this like you know what
do you think this is yeah this is a blip
and I dove into this because I saw the
headline and I'm like what the hell you
know and to find out what it is and this
was CNBC making a headline where there
really it isn't one
um and I don't win this stuff Diana Olaf
was talking about and what happened was
there is always buyers right on the edge
even in a bad Market there's a percent
of buyers that are right on the edge and
when they saw the madness happening with
svb and they hear you know the week
prior is what really drove it really was
an svb it was driven the week prior when
everyone was trying to talk Powell you
know buddy you don't need to do 25 you
need to do 50. and it was Larry Summers
on the weekend and all the weekend news
shows Larry Summers says he really needs
to put a half a point on this not just a
quarter point people on the edge were
reacting to that saying well if we're
gonna do it now we better do it now take
6.71 otherwise it's going to be seven
this wasn't the market moving back to
buy houses this is people on the edge
Pat it's on a blip they jumped in they
locked at 6.71 and they bought some
houses and also there was an increase in
sale of newly built homes in that last
week which is temporary because you know
what that was if you're a home builder
like Toll Brothers or Lanier Pat what
can you always do
you can use part of the home price to
Arbitrage the rate tell you what you go
get the rate and what I'll do is I'll
pay one point so instead of 6.75 you'll
get six and a quarter and so home
builders pushed a little blip on that
too but this is a blip this is not a
change in the mortgage Market according
to everything that I dove into
I I'm not particularly informed in this
specific issue but the housing market
has been historically kind of boom and
bust uh I know Austin specifically uh
the rates the for renting and for home
ownership went through the roof in the
last couple of years now they seem to
kind of if you look at Zillow which I
kind of do regularly all the home prices
have an arrow going down so the market
is kind of correcting itself but again
the mortgages and banks are obviously so
extremely interconnected that if banks
start failing this is going to have some
kind of cascading effect I'm just
wondering what the mortgage brokers are
telling their potential clients right
because in any sale it comes down to
what urgency and scarcity right so hey
you know the rate just dropped they're
not going to drop anytime soon you see
what Powell's doing out there the rates
are expected to go up you're lucky if
you get it at six and a half at this
point that's a great point I know I know
hey you know we can't go back to a year
ago where you could have got three and a
half you should have chose then now
we're at six and a half it could be
seven and a half next year time to go
time to go time to go inflation on the
corner I read it was a blip and that's
exactly if I was a mortgage broker would
I'd be saying to people we don't know
where this is going to go but it doesn't
look good you've been right on the edge
here why don't you pull the trigger on
the home let's get you locked in yeah
but you know if I'm that guy that was
looking to buy a house a year ago and I
missed the missed the rush and I could
have gotten at three and a half now
you're trying to sell me on six and a
half yeah that's an uncomfortable
situation are you gonna say something no
no I I completely agree this is trying
to be Nostradamus here gang this has
been a blast uh two things one uh go
order the book the white pill uh came
out December 1st five stars uh uh uh by
Michael malice let's put the link below
in the description as well as the chat
for people to go pick up again go pick
up the book white pill uh Michael malice
a tale of Good and Evil uh I got a
surprise gift as well for you it just
arrived your gift two days ago and I
rather than doing it on your birthday
you were out of town I want to do it
right now before it's too late and I
know your birthday was a minute ago but
it just arrived can we open the door and
get this gift for this guy
I think you're gonna like it I hope
you'll like it this is uh uh uh uh what
is happening it's a gift dude put it
behind him so at least you can see
hopefully he likes this gift oh bro are
you freaking kidding me open it up open
it up open it up let's see if you like
this gift or not it's my birthday today
we ordered a bed for your wife
all right let's see so the the reason
why I got you this gift is for obvious
reasons
okay so this is a Isaiah Thomas
autographed jersey
wow or Adam sauce because Adam grew up
your pops Detroit
happy birthday buddies
this is such a sick gift Isaiah Thomas
everyone was a Michael Jordan guy
everyone was a Larry Bird guy imagine I
was always Isaiah I like the Hipster
aspect of that yeah thank you this is I
appreciate that what's crazy I only own
one other Jersey and it's an Isaiah
Thomas jersey but it's not framing
put it up uh put it up in your bed
Isaiah if you ever see this Zeke put it
up in your bag and put it over here so
cool okay all right anyways uh we had a
blast Michael once again thanks for
coming out I know it was too early for
you but we had a good time hopefully we
woke you up and I know you woke a lot of
us up as well Florida is very well goes
to die apparently
it used to but it's changed it's used to
but it changed anyways gank have a great
uh weekend and we will do this again
next week take care everybody